Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und das hier ist die 88. Ausgabe.
Zum Jahresende. Heute ist der 2.12. 21,
gibt's natürlich nochmal Corona-Reaky, weil es gibt ja gerade ganz viel zu reflektieren,
nachdem ähm Sommer schon fast an Langeweile gestorben sind, passieren jetzt endlich wieder Dinge, neue Gesundheitsminister, neue Varianten, was wünscht man sich mehr, wenn man Pandemieberichterstatter ist?
Wir sind Pandemie-Gewinnler.
Ja
Erstmal.
Tim, hallo Leute.
Da sind wir wieder und wollen mal ein bisschen äh reflektieren, was was wir so ausgegraben haben und sonst so meinen.
Genau, wieder ein bisschen schlechte Laune verbreiten und Depressionen.
In hour Hamble äh Opinian, ne? Gab so in den Kommentaren auch so den einen oder anderen Vorwurf. Unsere Welt wäre ja dann doch äh zu klein.
Das äh kann natürlich jeder so bewerten wie er oder sie mag.
Inwiefern ich weil der muss ich hatte zwar neulich draufgeguckt aber äh inwiefern ist unsere Welt zu klein? Vielleicht können wir auf dieses Feedback mal eingehen.
Ja, na ja, weil wir irgendwie äh den ganzen Verschwörern äh auch nicht glauben und ähm.
Äh nicht in der Lage sind, die großen äh komplexen Weltprobleme, die äh die Ursache für die Pandemie sind zu verstehen. Sowas
gab's. Ähm ansonsten viele interessante Reflexionen und Anregungen und Verbesserungen. Vielen Dank auf jeden Fall.
Dafür aber ähm tja ganz ehrlich Leute wir blicken nach wie vor.
Ohne einen also wer kann das schon von sich behaupten, aber der Versuch hier ist nach wie vor,
in Ruhe auf die ganze Situation zu schauen, sich einen Reim draus zu machen und ein bisschen so ein Gefühl dafür zu entwickeln, was denn nun so die vertrauenswürdigsten Quellen sind,
Das kann sich natürlich auch immer alles ändern, aber die Erfahrung.
Über die Zeit hat sich eigentlich nicht groß geändert so. Die Wissenschaft ist äh fleißig und emsig am liefern, was Informationen betrifft und hat bisher eigentlich auch immer Recht behalten.
Deswegen ist das auch so ein bisschen unser ähm wie sagt man, unser Stern, den wir äh da an der Stelle primär folgen.
Und mir sind so zwei Dinge aufgefallen
was vielleicht mein vielleicht etwas besonderen Blick auf die Pandemie ausmacht, der vielleicht sich auch nicht immer mit dem Blick von,
Allen anderen
äh äh deckt äh so, weil ich ich habe das Gefühl mal trete ich der einen Gruppe ein bisschen auf die Füße, mal trete ich der anderen äh ein bisschen auf die Füße so mal mal bin ich irgendwie nicht ich sage mal enthusiastisch
äh äh genug so und äh dann äh bin ich äh für andere bin ich dann wieder sozusagen zu sehr ähm ja als als Geimpfter natürlich natürlich hirngewaschen und
es gibt ein ein Prinzip ähm so,
Worüber ich auch getwittert habe, so eine Erkenntnis, wie gesagt über über Jahrhunderte, äh dass du,
eben nicht mit rationalen Argumenten äh aus einer
Haltung herausgebracht werden äh kannst, in die du nicht mittels äh Rationalität äh hineingekommen bist und das bedeutet
dass je emotionaler du äh auf irgendetwas reagierst, also je mehr dir an irgendetwas liegt
je wichtiger dir etwas ist, umso emotionaler beteiligt bist so und umso weniger rational sind ist wahrscheinlich dein Blick.
Äh auf das das Ganze, das ist halt so ein Gesetz und in dem Zusammenhang ist mir aufgefallen, ich habe halt einen Großteil meines Lebens damit verbracht, Software zu schreiben.
Und wenn du halt Software schreibst, dann ist es ganz gut, wenn du dir so ein
etwas äh ja so eine gewisse Entspannung eigentlich zulegst. Also es hilft jetzt nichts allzu emotional äh äh zu werden beim beim Softwareentwickeln, weil
am Ende äh ja dem,
Das Programm funktioniert nicht besser, wenn du den Rechner anschreibst äh oder irgendwie auf die Tastatur äh einprügelst oder so, sondern.
Bist du sicher?
Ja also.
Nichts gebracht.
Äh also da ist manchmal so ein bisschen,
die Hand auflegen und Zuversicht und so hilft, hilft da ihr, aber äh ja, nee. Und äh ich es kann sein, dass einfach ich mein Denken auch dann in anderen Dingen,
für sich dann manchmal in so einer Art Flow reinkomme oder mich quasi irgendwie ja detachen
kann äh äh von von manchen Dingen und dann vielleicht etwas zu rational äh oder zu äh kühl oder kalt äh manchmal vielleicht auf auf die Dinge. Dann blicke, aber
Ja, das ist für mich eine Perspektive halt, die ich dann einnehme und sagen, bisschen die emotionslose Perspektive.
Und was so jetzt natürlich äh Verschwörungs äh Theorien oder so angeht, ich meine ich.
Ich habe nichts gegen eine gute Verschwörungstheorie so und es gibt ja auch Verschwörungen und äh insofern ist ja nicht so, dass es nicht irgendwelche mächtige Gruppen,
die irgendwie Dinge im Schilde führen, aber gerade jetzt natürlich bei covid oder Corona.
Das ist wirklich die langweiligste Verschwörung von der ich gehört hab. Ich mein alle Länder
also es gibt kein Land, was irgendwie jetzt gegen Impfungen ist, ja, wo man sagt, nee, Impfungen sind blöd. Und die ganzen Reichen und Mächtigen lassen sich auch alle impfen.
Äh so. Also in insofern ähm ja und dann.
Gegenüber jetzt Impfskeptikern äh jetzt neulich noch gesagt, also klar, was was die Impf-Skeptik oder Impfgegner nicht verstehen, ist, dass wir Geimpfte halt einfach so hirngewaschen sind, dass es uns
alles am äh Hintern vorbeigeht
äh so was die denken so, wir denken einfach nur, hört auf mit dem Mimimi, ist Pandemie jetzt, reißt euch mal zusammen und zieht einfach mit, sonst gibt's Druck, ja.
Das ist halt also wir sind wir sind halt wie gesagt wir sind da einfach äh ja äh sowieso äh äh
nicht mehr zu retten, genau. Nee, aber ganz, ganz, ganz im Ernst, ähm so ich überlege natürlich auch, äh so was soll man denn jetzt
entgegnen, wenn man weiß, okay äh Leute, die da quasi emotional, also durch Angst
letztlich durch eine im Grunde genommen durch eine Angststörung dort hineingeraten sind und es kann jedem passieren, eben so eine dass äh so eine Angststörung entwickelt und lass es, wenn
ein paar Fälle erlebst, wo Leute irgendwie nicht gut auf eine Impfung reagiert haben. Wir hatten ja bei uns bei uns ist das nicht so. Ich kenne halt
niemanden und ich habe nur von einem gehört, der die Impfung äh nicht vertragen hat,
äh so und irgendwie möglicherweise länger anhaltende Impfschäden äh davongetragen hat. So, aber es gibt's bestimmt
Es gibt bestimmt auch Leute, die halt äh sowas in ihrem Umfeld erleben oder noch schlimmer, so wenn nur es reicht halt einfach, wenn du von lauter Leuten umgeben bist, die Angst vor Impfung haben, um selber Angst vor Impfung zu entwickeln, so funktioniert das nun mal mit äh ansteckenden Emotionen so und was machst du da jetzt, wenn die Leute, wenn du weißt
Okay, die Leute sind da jetzt durch Angst äh äh reingekommen und klar gibt's halt auch Mechanismen da rauszukommen, aber man.
Mit aber mit sachlich oder mit Erklärung oder mit Argumenten dürfte man halt nicht weit kommen, sondern das geht halt auch wieder nur irgendwie unter Beteiligung des limbischen Systems, also das muss halt irgendwie aktiviert sein und das geht halt,
auch auch wiederum emotional und eigentlich müsste man das therapieren, weil es sich eben, wie gesagt, um Angststörungen oder Phobien handelt und jetzt auch, ja, ich meine, es gibt andere Leute, die können kein Blut sehen, äh so. Ich glaube, du gehörst zu der Kategorie, oder?
So ähm äh andere Leute haben halt einfach panische Angst vor Spritzen. Ja äh
So und andere haben halt Angst vor Spinnen oder Vögeln oder äh weiß ich nicht äh und das sind halt Phobien und wir wissen halt, wie die sich entwickeln und das ist jetzt auch nicht so
Ähm ja, also ist jetzt erstmal nicht so erstaunlich. So also insofern sollte man vielleicht da auch mal äh ein bisschen
jetzt, äh wenn man auf Leute guckt
die jetzt einfach irgendwo falsch abgebogen sind und eine Angststörung gegen Impfungen entwickelt haben und äh Postrationalisieren tun wir alle, ja und wie gesagt, wir wir sind geimpft und deswegen positionalisieren wir natürlich
äh weil auch nix Schlimmes passiert ist, äh dass das halt hilft und aber es ist halt nicht nur das.
Sondern äh im Grunde genommen kann man das ist das ist sind so wenn man denn Zahlen nennen will, wie gesagt habe ich dann immer so vier Zahlen äh die ich dann dann gerne nenne. Also wir haben jetzt Deutschland.
Tote durch 165 Millionen Impfdosen hatten wir beim letzten Mal auch schon rund 17.000 Tote durch, 6,7 Millionen Corona-Fälle.
Ja also und da kannst du irgendwie jetzt noch Sicherheitsfaktoren ohne Ende oben draufpacken und du kommst halt
immer äh dabei raus, dass äh ja wenn einmal das Virus komplett hier durchrollt oder du die komplette Bevölkerung äh durchimpfen lässt und das sind letztlich so die Alternativen oder dazwischen, bewegt sich das.
Sterben einfach mit Impfung nur 'nen Drittel der Leute so im im Endeffekt,
und äh ja deswegen es ist Impfung einfach gut und da kann man äh,
Und ich meine, die andere Seite so das einzige bei Kindern von null bis fünf Jahren, so kann man jetzt statistisch äh dann
nix drüber sagen. Da ist äh ja also da.
Sterben wahrscheinlich mit oder ohne Impfung äh irgendwie genauso viele, aber das ist sagt jetzt dann wiederum nicht notwendigerweise auch was über Long-Covid oder schwere Verläufe oder oder Ähnliches auch so.
Und
Was wir auch hatten, ja, die Impfung ist jetzt nicht das das Wundermittel äh so, mit der wir alle Probleme plötzlich äh gelöst kriegen, aber es ist halt das Beste und und Einfachste, was wir haben und
Das halte ich für die für die rationalste Einstellung. Es ist auch nicht es ist nicht ungefährlich, es ist eine gesundheitliche Belastung, man sollte sich schon nach der Impfung und auch nicht so tun, als wär's jetzt gar nichts und es könnte gar nix passieren.
Aber so ist es halt mit allem, so ist es mit allen Medikamenten, mit allen Interventionen äh die man macht. Na ja, okay.
Gut, gute Betrachtung. Ähm dem kann ich mich auch äh anschließen.
Ich wollt's jetzt mal genau wissen, wie ähm das jetzt eigentlich bei mir aussieht nach der Impfung und ich habe jetzt mal einen Antikörpertest vornehmen lassen.
Ah.
Bin in die Infektionspraxis äh meines Vertrauens äh gelatscht und habe mich ähm nicht ohne.
Also Gegenwehr natürlich nicht, aber nicht ohne wie soll ich sagen, wie nennt man denn dieses Gefühl? Also nicht ohne Skrupel äh wurde mir Blut abgenommen.
Skrupel ist, glaube ich, gar nicht das richtige Wort. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall, wie du schon richtig erwähnt hast. Ich ähm es ist nicht also dieses,
Ich kann schon Blut sehen. Das ist immer eine Frage des Kontextes und.
Mhm.
Problematisch wird's immer nur, wenn's meins äh ist und wenn irgendwie so organische Vorgänge so mir zu klar werden, also.
Organismische äh Rückkopplung. Also umso mehr mir sozusagen die Funktion meines eigenen Organismus vorzele,
umso mehr habe ich da so Mikrofon Lautsprecher äh Überlagerung und dann äh kann's auch mal mich komplett äh weg fiepen und ich bin wirklich schon in den absurdesten Situationen irgendwie hinten übergekippt, aber diesmal habe ich's äh geschafft und habe ein bisschen Blut abgegeben und
Aber ähm das Labor angesetzt dadrauf dort nochmal nach Corona-Antikörpern zu suchen.
Konkret nach den IGG-Antikörpern. Gibt ja so im Wesentlichen drei Arten von Antikörpern, mit denen wir's hier in dieser ganzen Debatte die ganze Zeit zu tun haben. IGA, M und G.
IGA und M sind so die als erstes äh aufgebaut nach einer Impfung oder auch nach einer Infektion. Die ersten, die quasi kommen,
Die IGA mehr so im Schleimhäutebereich, IGM mehr so im Körper. Das ist sozusagen so die die,
den Noteinsatz, wo die,
Polizeistreife, die schnell mal gerufen wird, die Feuerwehr, die erstmal so Schlimmeres verhindern soll.
Und dann für die etwas langfristigeren äh Effekt kommen dann halt die IGG so nach drei, vier Wochen bauen die sich so richtig auf und die kann man halt messen,
und dann wird die Menge bestimmt und äh dass es dann ähm die habe ich schon wieder vergessen äh.
Wie man so schön sagt oder.
Der TTA äh genau und es ist ähm vor allem.
Ist die äh Einheit, mit der man das Miss ist quasi BAU pro Milliliter, also BAU steht für.
Und ähm wenn man so im Netz rumklickt, gibt's so die unterschiedlichsten Untersuchungen da drüber, wie viele man davon haben sollte, aber so unter unter 50 ist definitiv quasi keinerlei Schutz vorhanden.
Und da drüber kann man dann lange darüber diskutieren ab wann man jetzt genug hat oder nicht. Jemand
wurde man mit 200 in meinem Umfeld nach der zweiten Impfung, nach drei Monaten gemessen und da war dann schon so der Rat so, jetzt wär aber auch mal ein Bus da fällig.
Und ähm ja und ich äh bin mit,
280 aus dem Rennen rausgegangen, wobei man sagen muss, das war jetzt auch ziemlich genau vier Wochen, also idealer Zeitpunkt nach der Booster-Impfung.
Und ja jetzt äh fühle ich mich natürlich wie das,
Schwert im Pandemienebel, ja also ich,
bin ich wahrscheinlich nicht.
Aber zeigt auf jeden Fall ähm, dass das gewirkt hat. Also ähm angeblich gab's in der Praxis niemanden aus dem Team, der einen höheren Wert hat.
Ah, okay.
Das finde ich schon mal ganz.
BAU-Rekordhalter, ja. Ja. Ja, vielleicht äh genau, vielleicht sollte man das in den Impfpass äh äh.
Baumeister bin ich sozusagen.
Dass du dann quasi deine deine BAU Punkt genau deine BAU-Punkte stattdessen und je je nachdem wie auf wie viel Punkte du kommst, ist deinen Aufenthaltszeit in der Kneipe begrenzt, äh so oder.
Oder oder für äh was weiß ich, die die begrenzten Plätze werden dann nach BAU-Score vergeben oder so.
Aber das ist doch wieder die Spaltung der Gesellschaft. Fabel, das wollen wir doch nicht.
Mhm mhm äh es ist dann genau würde man das dann nennen äh.
Oder so äh so wie.
Und äh ja Diskriminierung äh nach äh äh Immunsystem.
Na gut, also muss man ja auch nicht machen, aber so für die Nerds unter euch ist das sicherlich mal ganz interessant. Äh man muss das selber zahlen, hat aber nicht viel gekostet. Ich weiß nicht, fünfundzwanzig Euro irgendwie sowas und ist für die ja auch, sagen wir mal, ein überschaubarer ähm,
Vorgang.
Ganz genau, wie lange das dann im Labor dauert, aber der Test ist jetzt nicht so komplex und äh im Wesentlichen ist halt so die Blutabnahme. Die da mit reinkommt. Ja und dann kann man vielleicht ein Bild gewinnen und hätte ich jetzt.
Im Rückblick vielleicht mal öfter machen sollen vor der Impfung. Wäre es interessant gewesen, ob man schon mal Kontakt hatte.
Und dann jeweils äh vier Wochen nach Erst- und Zweitimpfungen, habe ich aber nicht gemacht.
Nur da ich aber keine wirkliche Impfreaktion hatte in dem Sinne, also jetzt auch von dem Booster. Ich.
Weiß auch nicht, warum das bei mir ist, aber ich weiß nicht, ich werde geimpft, ich mag nichts davon, gar nix, keine Kopfschmerzen, kein Fieber, keine Niedergeschlagenheit, keine keine Müdigkeit, einfach nix außerhalb,
Die Einstichstelle tut so ein bisschen weh, aber das ist halt auch irgendwie nix so.
Vielleicht so abends beim ersten in der in der ersten Nacht beim Einschlafen ein bisschen, wenn man sich so auf die Seite drehen will, aber das war's dann auch schon und insofern finde ich das jetzt mal einen ganz interessanten Wert so, den ich jetzt vielleicht dann auch öfter mal checken und verfolgen kann.
Ja, klingt gut.
Mal gucken, wie's Deutschland so geht.
Ja. Also die Zahlen ähm,
sehen jetzt nicht so schlecht aus. Ähm wir haben definitiv den Gipfel der vierten Welle überschritten kann man jetzt sagen ähm,
die Inzidenz ist jetzt nach Publikationsdatum für Deutschland auf dreihundertvierunddreißig
von hunderttausend in den letzten sieben Tagen gefallen von fast 500. Also es geht geht halt ganz gut.
Ab äh so mit einem
R-Wert äh auch von deutschlandweit 0 Komma acht acht. Das könnte jetzt besser sein, aber in einigen Bundesländern geht's äh äh nochmal deutlich schneller äh runter und was aber
sagen wirklich erfreulich oder.
Ähm ja doch kann man kann man sagen äh erfreulich äh ist ist das äh es auch so zu sein scheint, dass wir äh erstmal den Peak auch bei den Todesfällen äh überschritten haben.
Könnten äh so seit jetzt ähm,
ja einer Woche ungefähr ist es jetzt wir sind jetzt bei 2tausend6hundert immer noch auf einem hohen Niveau, aber auch da,
könnte jetzt äh die äh äh die Trendwende erreicht sein und müsste eigentlich erreicht sein.
Also 2600 pro Woche. Ne? Sieben.
In den letzten sieben Tagen genau äh 2tausend6hundert Todesfälle und ähm,
Ja dann lohnt halt immer so der Blick nochmal äh in welchen
Altersgruppen sich das denn abspielt oder sich jetzt was abspielt und da sehen wir aber auch einen Rückgang der Inzidenz in allen,
Altersgruppen ähm nach wie vor am am höchsten mit
786 ähm sind immer noch die Fünf- bis Vierzehnjährigen und dann.
Ja bei bei dreihundert
fünfzig beziehungsweise 3achtzig äh liegen dann die 15 bis Vierunddreißigjährigen und
die äh äh fünfunddreißig bis neunundfünfzigjährigen, die liegen jetzt quasi so in der in der Mitte dann interessanterweise die
5 bis 14-jährigen haben nach wie vor mit zweihundertachtzig äh,
noch äh ja eher niedrige Inzidenzen und besonders erfreulich bei den Älteren so 60 bis 79 und 80 Plus die sind so in der Gegend hundert,
achtundfünfzig beziehungsweise 166 und auch wieder rückläufig so, das heißt ähm ja das
sieht halt ähm jetzt grade nicht so schlecht aus äh also kurzfristig beziehungsweise die die Trends,
zeigen in die in die richtige Richtung, aber ähm so,
Natürlich, dass es jetzt alles noch Delta und ähm ja.
Aber es hilft natürlich auch äh der Omikon-Verbreitung entgegen.
Zu wirken grundsätzlich, weil ähm
Ja, das ist natürlich ein Ergebnis auch von weniger Kontakten ist und von mehr Maskendisziplin und ähm ja Plus der Impfungen, die wirken natürlich alle sich auch auf auf um aus und
insofern jetzt äh ja ähm gerade kurzfristig.
Erstmal die Zahlen eher erfreulich in den meisten Bundesländern ähm,
Wenn man jetzt in die Bundesländer reingucken ja auch Thüringen und äh Sachsen und Sachsen-Anhalt fallen die Zahlen aber mit
noch mit ja 730 bis 8dreißig bewegen die sich noch auf einem recht hohen Niveau
Brandenburg verharrt irgendwie mehr oder weniger bei 600 nur langsamen Abwärtstrend.
Und der Rest ist so horizontal, ne?
Ja und der Rest ist dann so eher horizontal, wobei ähm ja Schleswig-Holstein nach wie vor irgendwie äh machen die nicht so richtig mit bei der Pandemie in Schleswig-Holstein. Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, was die da äh treibt, aber wir hatten ja
Schon mal schon mal den Witz äh als dort irgendwie äh die die Abstandsregeln äh rauskamen so in Norddeutschland, dass sie meinen irgendwie was so nahe so mehr aneinander ran äh äh treten jetzt, dass das vielleicht irgendwie.
Sowieso ähm was sein könnte, ich weiß nicht.
Gut, also man kann daran auch ablesen, dass der Rückgang der Zahlen im Wesentlichen der Rückgang der Zahlen in Thüringen, Sachsen, Sachsen-Anhalt und Brandenburg ist.
Ja? Also würde sich unser Mittel nur aus allen anderen Bundesländern beziehen, dann hätte sich da nicht so sehr viel dran getan.
Ja, wobei natürlich ja gut äh klar die bevölkerungsreichsten Länder machen natürlich auch eine ganze Menge aus. Ich gucke gerade, äh wie ist es denn? Bayern da.
Gut, aber auch bei Nordrhein-Westfalen ist es halt nur so ein sanftes Absinken so, aber immerhin ist Nordrhein-Westfalen mit 2hundertfuffzig, 260 im niedrigen Bereich. Meine Güte, das ist das, was wir jetzt als.
Ja ja und ja gut Bayern, ich glaube der ja der Rückgang in Bayern äh hat sich.
Du hast Recht, du hast Recht, das habe ich natürlich total übersehen. In Bayern gab's tatsächlich auch einen starken Rückgang. Das hat natürlich auch noch mal eine große Rolle gespielt. Und da ist der Rückgang sogar wirklich sehr gut.
Ja und natürlich Bayern mit den 12 Millionen zieht natürlich dann auch den Bundesdurchschnitt äh ganz gut mit runter.
Ja ist richtig. Also sagen wir mal so die Länder, die jetzt besonders betroffen waren, die haben erhebliche Fortschritte erzielt und das war auch bitter nötig.
Insgesamt könnte schon noch ein bisschen mehr äh passieren, wird jetzt ganz spannend äh.
Sein zu sehen, wie.
Sich das jetzt mit Weihnachten verhält. Also wenn man jetzt so ein bisschen Glück haben, dann ist auf den letzten Metern zum Weihnachtswochen so eine Weihnachtswoche,
haben sich noch mal alle so richtig am Riemen gerissen und äh Weihnachten selber trägt nicht unbedingt noch mal dazu bei, dass es sich groß verbreitet.
Davon ab, wie groß die Weihnachtsfeiern sind und wie sehr sich die Leute so mischen. Dann haben wir natürlich so ein bisschen die Meldedelle.
Erst Anfang des Jahres wirklich wieder sagen können wie es denn ausgegangen ist und das ist natürlich jetzt aber auch genau der Zeitraum wo,
in Deutschland sich so richtig breit machen wird und von daher wird es spannend,
zu sehen, ob wir so gerade noch soeben uns weggeduckt bekommen haben, bevor es richtig reinknallt oder ob der Zug eigentlich schon längst abgefahren ist.
Ja also zur Ommi Collen kommen wir ja später
äh äh noch, aber da, weil wir grad bei den äh Zahlen sind, kann man dann vielleicht kann ich dann vielleicht gleich auch schon mal die die Omikron äh Zahlen
nennen für für Deutschland so und da kriegen wir bisher nur wöchentliche äh Zahlen. Also wir haben jetzt nur die Zahlen.
Kalenderwoche 46 bis jetzt 49 und
da die die nackten Fallzahlen, die jetzt gemeldet worden sind vom RKI so in der KW achten in der KW 64 hatten wir den ersten Fall
in der Woche drauf waren's dann vierundzwanzig Fälle, dann hundertsechzehn und in der letzten Woche hundertdreiundsechzig äh so.
Ja also ähm,
Natürlich können wir da von einer größeren Dunkelziffer ausgehen. Das ist das, was jetzt gemessen wurde. Wahrscheinlich ist mir eher in der Größenordnung dann von 1000 Fällen deutschlandweit
ausgehen gerade, die,
tief sind und ähm ja das kann natürlich jetzt schon ganz schnell aus äh durchstarten. Anderen Ländern haben wir ja gesehen so drei, vier Wochen oder so.
Äh können da völlig ausreichen, aber ähm man kann auch davon ausgehen, dass uns die großen Welle
erst im Januar treffen wird so oder.
Noch mal kurz auf die Entwicklung der positiv äh Rate und der Tests also Tests gab's in der KW neunundvierzig, das ist die Woche bis zum zwölften zwölften.
21 gab's.
Quasi Millionen Tests. Das ist ein äh weniger als davor, wo wir den totalen Peak hatten mit bis zu 1,9 Millionen Tests und die Positivrate hat.
Etwas abgenommen. Jetzt das zweite Mal in Folge.
Sind wir jetzt auf immer noch nicht so geilen neunzehn Komma sieben fünf Prozent positiven Quote. Ähm ja immerhin das zweite Mal gefallen.
Seit seinem Maximum von 21 auch das unterstreicht im Prinzip das was wir bei den Infektionszahlen derzeit sehen bei der Inzidenz, also der Trend nach unten ist real und der.
Findet statt. Das kann man glaube ich mit Sicherheit sagen, ne. Wie lange er noch so weitermacht.
Unklar, aber soweit äh lässt sich das auf jeden Fall bestätigen.
Ja. Also
äh eine sinkende positiven Quote bei weniger Tests ist da glaube ich ein ganz deutlicher Anhaltspunkt. Und dem Zusammenhang vielleicht auch nochmal, weil weil ich das auch äh sehe, es gibt natürlich
äh mein das diskutieren wir hier seit seit Anfang der der Sendung, dass die Daten nicht toll sind
bei uns in Deutschland und es gibt natürlich auch immer wieder äh äh dann so gewisse Fehler und natürlich auch Fehlerdarstellungen in der Politik und wenn ich dann immer so bemerkenswert, wenn dann gerade Leute.
So jetzt ich sage mal aus der eher skeptischen äh äh Ecke, sage ich mal oder überskeptischen
äh Ecke. Ähm dann äh sich dann plötzlich mit Vehemenz auf
jeden einzelnen Fehler oder Missstand stürzen, was ich sag mal natürlich man man kritisieren,
kann, aber daraus dann den Schluss zu ziehen,
alle Daten irgendwie völlig wertlos sind, ja? Das ist dann äh äh die Stelle, wo's dann äh wirklich irrational äh wird, weil bei allen Fehlern in den Daten so
halt äh doch äh Trends,
aus den verschiedenen Daten dann doch äh sehr gut ablesen, so man darf halt nur nicht überinterpretieren, aber ähm ja ich bin mir halt
jetzt grade sehr, sehr sicher, dass die Inzidenzen zurückgehen. So und,
genauso sicher wie ich mir bin dass halt Impfungen einen gewissen Schutz bieten.
Noch mal ein bisschen nach Europa Ampen schauen und mal die anderen Länder mal äh wieder mit reinziehen, die wir jetzt lange Zeit ignoriert haben.
Denke ja mal so ein Blick in die Nachbarländer wäre vielleicht nicht verkehrt.
Genau, also Dänemark scheint so grade.
Die meisten Fälle zu melden und Dänemark ist ja auch grade zusammen mit UK,
in dem Ruf vor allem viel Ombyon abbekommen zu haben. Da setzen sich diese Varianten derzeit sehr schnell durch.
Sind natürlich auch die beiden Länder,
die am meisten sequenzieren und von daher den geschärftesten Blick haben. Das kann natürlich dann auch dazu beitragen, dass die ähm generell durch ihr Testregime.
Und ihre Überwachung der Pandemie dort Vorteile haben, andererseits testen tun wir auch genug
und man kann ja anhand der PCR-Testergebnisse schon sehen oder zumindest eine Vorstellung davon bekommen
Variantenverteilung ist, haben wir ja schon besprochen, ne? Also wenn dieser eine äh dieser Auftritt also quasi mal einer dieser Subtests
PCR-Tests äh nicht äh anschlägt, aber der Rest schon, dann ist klar, okay,
Corona liegt vor, aber eben nicht in der bisherigen Variante, soll in dem Fall eben äh in der Omikon-Variante. Also ganz unabhängig jetzt von den Varianten, Dänemark, UK und äh die Schweiz sind vorne
auch äh wieder alte Bekannte wie äh Tschechien, wobei die jetzt schon wieder ihre Welle ähm
Ihre fünfte Welle mittlerweile, die auch wieder richtig fett und heftig war, hinter sich äh gebracht haben. Genauso ist äh Belgien aufgestellt.
Noch ansteigend äh ist es dann in Norwegen, also die Reihenfolge, die ich jetzt hier wähle, ist quasi so wie die Fälle grade sind. Niederlande scheint durch äh Lockdown-Maßnahmen auch so ein bisschen Infektion wieder in den Griff bekommen,
nachdem das ziemlich äh fett war Frankreich steigt langsam an. Äh Spanien hat wohl jetzt auch Ommi Kron steigt äh an.
Ja und dann so Polen, Deutschland und so weiter scheint's noch nicht ganz so erreicht zu haben. Da kann man jetzt nur drüber spekulieren. Also auf jeden Fall.
Ähm in manchen Ländern geht's schon richtig los und ich denke, man.
Sagt nix Falsches, wenn man davon ausgehen kann, dass halt einfach jetzt so eine fünfte Welle relativ schnell folgen wird und in manchen Ländern geht's halt jetzt schon los und andere wie wir, da geht's ja ein, zwei Wochen später los.
Mehr Österreich erteilt auch äh ja ähm.
Eine fette Welle hinter sich, aber ist auch ganz gut ganz schnell da jetzt wieder äh runtergekommen so muss man sagen.
Und äh ja die Schweden äh stehen halt gerade im Moment auch ganz gut.
Äh muss man muss man sagen wobei.
Halt ähm wenn man jetzt auf die Toten guckt
Das Problem bei den Inzidenzvergleichen ist ja immer, dass den ganz andere Testregime zugrunde liegen. Und dass zum Beispiel äh die Dänemark Zahlen, wenn die so hoch sind, ist es was ganz anderes
als ja
wenn, keine Ahnung, bei uns oder äh ja bei bei uns die Zahlen, also wahrscheinlich äh muss man auf die deutschen Inzidenzen Faktor zwei oder drei nochmal nehmen, um sie mit den
dänischen vergleichbar zu machen und das
zeigt sich dann halt, wenn man dann wiederum das das Ranking nach Todesfällen sich anguckt, wobei das natürlich auch zeitlich jetzt hinterher läuft.
Man da auch äh aber da kann man dann sehen, dass zum Beispiel gerade jetzt Polen, sei es bei den Todesfällen, ist Polen jetzt ganz oben und Tschechien auch und Griechenland.
Wobei Griechenland. Bei den Inzidenzen jetzt gar nicht so wild aussah und Österreich, ja da geht's jetzt auch runter, weil die sind halt auch noch.
Extrem hoch und dann sieht man zum Beispiel, dass auch,
dass jetzt wenn man Deutschland und Dänemark vergleicht, dann sind wir jetzt im Moment bei vier Komma vier zwei äh,
Ähm im im Pro äh eine Million glaube ich ist das ähm,
ja in den letzten sieben Tagen und ähm wo grade und Dänemark ähm,
ja ist bei eins Komma fünf zwo, also ein Drittel, ja. Ähm so wären,
bei den Inzidenzen. Ähm,
Plagen sie ja deutlich drüber und wenn man jetzt drei Wochen zurückgeht oder so, dann äh ja lagen sie ungefähr gleich gleich auf. So kann man das
vielleicht sagen, das heißt, die jetzigen Todes äh Zahlen äh zeigen dann, dass äh ja
dieser Faktor zwei bis dreiäh bei der Inzidenz eigentlich in in in Dänemark also sie messen äh zwei bis dreimal besser äh deren,
Ist zwei- bis dreimal niedriger als unsere Dunkelziffer.
Ja und wenn man jetzt äh natürlich ist ist dann immer die die Debatte ja äh oder die alte Debatte hm welche.
Welche Strategie äh war denn jetzt bisher insgesamt die Beste und dann kann man halt auf kumulierte Zahlen gucken und da sieht man dann das was immer die Tschechen auch gemacht haben. Das war nicht gut, weil
Die haben bisher einfach mal äh so kumuliert jetzt äh dreieinhalbtausend.
Ja dreitausenddreihundert mittlerweile von von einer Million äh äh,
Menschen verloren, was halt so ja 3,3 Prozent äh sind. Ja.
Tschechien sind jetzt seit Beginn der Pandemie 3,3 Prozent der Bevölkerung an covid verstorben.
Bist du jetzt nicht wieder um einen Zehner verrutscht? Das ist ja pro Million hier, ne?
Ja äh drei Komma okay drei äh null Komma okay null Komma drei Prozent.
Das ist auch schon eine Menge. So.
Null Kommadrei. Ja.
Krankheit.
Ja, 0,33 Prozent genau und.
Bei uns äh ja sind's halt bisher eins äh null Komma eins zwei Prozent. So,
und Dänemark äh ja sind's null Komma null fünf Prozent so genau.
Null Komma null fünf Prozent, ja. Also die sind wesentlich äh besser dabei und Finnland und Norwegen sind bisher auch noch deutlich besser gefahren, ja. Aber,
so im im Vergleich jetzt äh also,
ansonsten Schweden ja ist jetzt ungefähr auf so schlimm wie Österreich, also es äh Schweden war am Anfang halt schlimm und äh seit.
Eigentlich in also 2021 läuft es in in Schweden äh äh besser, also seitdem hatten sie da nicht mehr so große Wellen während
Österreich halt äh jetzt gerade in der letzten Welle ganz gut aufgeholt hat. Ja leider.
Wir können uns jetzt hier in den Zahlen natürlich noch äh tausendfach äh verfangen. Insgesamt kann man feststellen, es es wütet auf jeden Fall in Europa noch äh ziemlich viel so und es sind ähm Europa an sich halt noch schwer zu kämpfen mit.
Mit Corona.
Ja, die immer in die ganze Welt hat, hat noch noch schwer zu kämpfen. Ja, die meisten Leute auf der Welt haben den Virus noch nicht gesehen, ne.
Ja gut, aber gibt aber auf jeden Fall Länder, die mit ihrer Strategie zumindest äh derzeit überhaupt nicht groß auffallen, ne. Also Japan oder äh China nach wie vor.
Neuseeland ist nach wie vor irgendwie in in Neuseeland ja.
Kann man das essen bei irgendwie neun Komma fünf sechs von einer Million? Also zehn pro Million,
Tote, das ist irgendwie das wäre auf auf Deutschland äh umgerechnet, äh wenn wir so gut,
So gut geschafft hätten wie Neuseeland hätten wir jetzt statt hundertsiebentausend,
Toten. Ähm ja, hätten wir unter tausend gehabt irgendwie. Neunhundert oder so. Ne, ne. Das wäre.
00000 tote Meer oder weniger. Kommst doch jetzt auch nicht mehr drauf an, oder.
Ja, genau. Was was war jetzt genau 100.000 Tote mehr oder weniger.
Kleine Side Note in den USA ist jetzt die häufigste Todesursache für Kinder.
Covid.
Also ist ja auch immer so eine Betrachtungsweise äh inwiefern ist denn jetzt das sozusagen gefährlich für äh Kinder und dann vergleicht dann so die Kinder und die Eltern und dann sagt man immer so, na ja.
Ist ja was für große und die Kinder sind ja nicht gefährdet nur gibt's halt.
Andere Krankheiten, die Kinder eben bedrohen und die man ja eigentlich auch in der Regel als gefährlich
wahrnimmt, ne? Also Grippe oder Lungenentzündung oder Leukämie ähm alles Mögliche.
Und ja laut der Statistik ähm ist es mittlerweile so, dass.
Covid jetzt sozusagen da auch schon statistisch auffällig wird. Ne.
Man muss natürlich aber auch dazu äh sagen ähm.
Also gut, diese bei diesen Zahlen okay, ist halt erstmal Altersgruppe null bis neunzehn äh Zoom, also insofern
äh ja es ist jetzt nicht nur nicht nur Kinder und dann ist natürlich die die Inzidenz mit,
6hundert Todesfällen pro Jahr gut ähm.
Also es ist jetzt auch äh in in absoluten Werten noch relativ gering und es ist auch die einzige sagen und es ist nur nur die
das was sozusagen natürliche Todesfälle angeht, das heißt äh Unfälle oder andere äh Dinge
sind da noch äh sind nach wie vor also bedrohen Kinder in viel größerem Maße als jetzt Krankheiten.
Also school shootings sind sicherlich auch noch ein richtig nennenswertes Problem, aber das ist ja jetzt für diese.
Egal, ich wollte jetzt auch da keine Panik machen, ich wollte das nur so kontextualisieren, zu sagen was was sozusagen Bedrohungspotential betrifft, vielleicht nicht immer nur schauen, wie verhält sich äh Corona jetzt einerseits bei jüngeren versus Älteren.
Airbus vollkommen klar ist, äh wie das ausgeht, sondern eben auch einfach mal zur Seite schauen, so wie verhält sich die Krankheit im Verhältnis zu anderen Krankheiten.
Und da äh ist es halt on the rise. Also es ist definitiv auch für Jugendliche und Kinder oder halt ist das wirklich unter neunzehn, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht genau.
Zu sagen, es ist die es ist die tödlichste Infektionskrankheit äh gerade in den USA unter.
Jungen Menschen, so könnte man das vielleicht oder die, die die meisten Tode unter jungen Menschen verursacht, aber es ist halt äh trotzdem
ähm auch bei Kindern, ich sage mal Herzkrankheiten aber eine doppelt so hohe Inzidenz äh äh was Todesfallinzidenz
ertrinken, das Dreifache äh so wie du schon sagtest, so ein Schusswaffen äh ist tatsächlich äh sagen auch noch mal fast viermal, also es sterben viermal so mehr
mehr Kinder in den USA an durch Schusswaffen als an an an covid und nochmal ein bisschen mehr, also ich glaube nicht fünf, sechs mal so viele bei Autounfällen.
Ja, also das relativiert das Ganze, aber macht's trotzdem, ich sage mal, was Infektionskrankheiten angeht, äh ja,
Es ist definitiv die äh äh die die am die meisten Todesfälle verursacht.
Schauen wir mal auf die Impfkampagne in Deutschland. Ähm
Das ist ja eigentlich eine sehr lebendige Geschichte. Also wir haben
Rekorde. Es werden werden wirklich sehr viele Impfungen derzeit verpasst. Also diese ganze Booster-Phase.
Ist äh viel intensiver zumindest zeitlich dichter gedrängter könnte man sagen als es eben zur Hochzeit ähm Mitte Ende Juni war.
Ähm da haben wir's eigentlich ähm zu keinem Zeitpunkt geschafft, da mehr als eine Million.
Ähm.
Pro Woche hinzubekommen und das ist uns jetzt aber locker äh gelungen und ja, das ist natürlich vor allem auf die Booster-Impfung zurückzuführen, die jetzt grade so ein bisschen gepiekt haben.
Vor ein paar Tagen.
Das jetzt schon ein ein permanenter Downwort-Trend ist, kann ich nicht so richtig sagen, aber äh es scheint jetzt zumindest so diese erste Welle der Leute
zu sein, so wie wir so, weißt du so, ah, was, Booster gibt's, zack, wo kann ich den kriegen, die einfach dann auch,
alles in Bewegung setzen, um sich einen Termin zu holen und das war natürlich jetzt so der Ansturm in den letzten Tagen. Sicherlich auch so ein bisschen gefördert durch das nahende Weihnachten.
Was viele Leute sicherlich dann auch so als Motivation genommen haben, so nach dem Motto äh nochmal ordentlich durchpustern, bevor man dann bei Oma äh am Braten sitzt. Ähm.
Genau. Erstimpfung waren ja gegen Ende November angestiegen, dann ging das wieder zurück
bisschen schwer zu sagen, aber das mag so mit ersten Impfpflicht-Debatten zu tun gehabt haben, höheren Zwängen und auch vor allem der Debatte in Österreich oder der Einführung der Impfpflicht in Österreich.
Dass das einfach einen gewissen äh Effekt hat, ja, kann ja zum Beispiel auch einen Effekt gehabt haben, so im südlichen Bayern.
Wo dann sozusagen auch so,
Landesgrenzen überschritten werden, wenn wir nicht rausfinden. Dann ging's äh zurück bis vor einer Woche. Seitdem steigen die Erstimpfungen zart wieder an.
Obama dazu sagen muss.
Alles nicht in dem Maße, wie man das eigentlich sehen wollen würde. Ja, also es ist einfach nicht äh genug, da da müsste wirklich mehr passieren.
Ähm passiert aber nicht. Ähm von daher sollte man da jetzt nichts zu optimistisch sein, aber auch vielleicht nicht unbedingt ähm Pessimist. Also wir haben ungefähr so äh siebenundsiebzigtausend.
Nee, stimmt gar nicht. Äh Quatsch erzählt.
Ähm ja und auch ungefähr so 70.000 erste Impfungen pro Tag gehabt.
Zweitimpfung liegen derzeit auf demselben. Level zum Vergleich, Boosterimpfung ging halt irgendwie 8hunderttausend pro Tag raus. Ja,
Wie entwickelt sich das weiter, schwierig zu sagen? Also wenn man auf eine Simulation schaut, die so ein bisschen guckt, okay, bei der aktuellen Bereitschaft,
Erstimpfungen zu machen wenn das so weitergeht dann hätten wir eine Erstimpfung.
Von der Bevölkerung Mitte Februar auch erst so bei fünfundsiebzig.
Prozent vollständige Impfung.
Was einfach immer noch alles viel zu viel zu wenig ist. Also da muss schon nochmal äh was anderes passieren.
Also mein, es zeigt natürlich schon eine Wirkung, aber äh eigentlich will man schon irgendwo 90 Prozent und mehr möchte man schon haben, glaube ich. Ja.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir das erreichen werden. Also zumindest sieht es nicht danach aus, dass wir das erreichen werden. Ein,
Faktor in der ganzen Geschichte war natürlich die Verfügbarkeit von Impfstoffen. Wird ja jeder sicherlich mitbekommen haben, dass äh Karl Lauterbach, nachdem er Gesundheitsministerium übernommen hat, dann erstmal eine Bestandsaufnahme.
In Auftrag gegeben hat, die wohl relativ schnell äh die Information geliefert hat, dass nicht genug da war.
Oder zumindest jetzt für die nächste Zeit nicht genug da gewesen wäre.
War ein bisschen verwirrend dem Ganzen zu folgen, habe da so verschiedenste Berichte gesehen, äh was denn nun irgendwie stimmt oder nicht oder wie denn das nun gerechnet wird und moderner und halbe Dosierung und so weiter. Auf jeden Fall,
auf EU-Ebene noch mal ordentlich nachbestellt worden und zusätzlich,
äh Karl Lauterbach auch noch ungenutzte Bestände aus anderen europäischen Ländern angefordert,
in irgendeiner Form überhaupt nicht abgenommen würden, also was wie Rumänien oder so, was natürlich total dramatisch ist, aber es war dann halt wohl auch schon so Impfstoffe, wo sie dann gesehen haben, so und die werden wir hier nie los. Also,
Nach dem Motto weg wegschmeißen oder äh woanders hintun.
Ja und von daher, so wie ich das mitbekommen habe, scheint wohl die Versorgungssituation,
sichergestellt zu sein, ob das dann halt abgerufen wird, steht aufm anderen Blatt.
Ja ich bin mir da jetzt noch nicht ganz so sicher äh was jetzt die Versorgungssituation.
Angeht, dass die jetzt wirklich äh äh sichergestellt,
ist äh so äh und ob wirklich jetzt die der Rückgang auch der Zahl der Impfungen auf nachlassenden Impfwunsch oder oder Impfbereitschaft,
zurückzuführen ist, ich glaube nicht, dass wir da schon an dem,
an der Stelle angekommen sind, aber es ist natürlich auch alles jetzt spekulativ ähm so oder.
Ja, es ist äh spirituativ. Es wird äh einfach von allem abhängt, ne. Ich meine, es wird ähm von der weiteren Debatte über Impfpflichten abhängen und wie gut das angenommen wird, wenn's eine äh gibt.
Ähm aber man kann sich, glaube ich, nicht dieser Illusion hingeben, dass wir jetzt irgendwie mühelos auf 90 Prozent kommen. Aber.
Es ist natürlich insofern jetzt das richtige Verhalten, dass man erstmal sagt, wir müssen überhaupt erstmal das Angebot machen, weil was wir.
Schlimmer als wenn es alle auf einmal dann so oh Gott jetzt oh Mikro und jetzt muss ich mich aber doch mal impfen ja war alles ganz schlimm und dann ist es wieder nix da so das äh wär's ja auch nicht.
Nee und das wird natürlich das Problem ist, das wird natürlich irgendwann plötzlich dann ganz schnell.
Also spätestens dann mit der Verfügbarkeit neuer Impfstoffe glaube ich werden dann viele Leute dann auch sagen, ah soll ich mir jetzt wirklich noch den den alten holen und.
Also im Moment man sagen,
auf jeden Fall so weil es ist da das wird noch Monate dauern bis es was anderes gibt und im Moment macht es halt total Sinn äh noch aber es wird halt irgendwann kippen und dann ist natürlich die Frage äh so
man will ja jetzt auch nicht nicht unnötig äh dann äh größere Mengen an an Impfstoffen.
Dann wegkippen, aber dann, das hat mir auch schon beim letzten Mal war's noch völlig unklar, ist es,
ob der Nächste Impfstoff denn dann ähm sagen ein Kombi-Impfstoff sein wird, der dann gegen mehrere Varianten äh schützt oder,
man äh dann ja trotzdem quasi äh äh noch äh Impfungen äh ja,
sage mal gegen gegen die alten Varianten braucht oder ob man die vielleicht irgendwann dann wieder hervorholen muss, weil alte Varianten dann dann wieder äh durchlaufen, aber gut, wir werden sehen, weil die andere Sache ist aber grundsätzlich selbst wenn wir nur,
auf die 90 Prozent jetzt kommen oder sagen wir fünfundachtzig Prozent äh der Rest wird sich dann halt einfach anstecken.
Zur Not mehrfach, wenn sie sich dann nicht impfen lassen so, aber so nach zwei, drei äh äh Covid äh,
Erkrankungen oder so hast du dann auch einen guten Impfschutz?
Stimmt. Das ist natürlich ein Aspekt, ne? Also es wird dann sowieso irgendwie geimpft. Entweder natürlich oder halt per Spritze.
Und.
Zufällig auch äh ja also natürliche Immunität ist schon auch ganz gut vor allem in Verbindung mit der mit der Impfung. Die hält halt schon wie das zu erwarten war. Ähm
hält, die halt ganz ganz gut ähm so, aber ähm also natürliche Erkrankung ist
scheint so ungefähr in der Größenordnung wie zwei äh äh Dosen jetzt zwei Dosen RNA Impfstoff äh in etwa ähm zu.
Wirken jetzt bei der TZL-Immunität und äh,
Ja und und hält auch relativ lange, aber ist halt trotzdem nicht nicht unbedingt zu empfehlen ähm ohne Impfung. So es teuer bezahlt dann.
Ja. Paar Anmerkungen äh äh noch, um vielleicht das Impfthema dann auch erst mal äh zumachen zu Köln. Ihr habt noch ein paar Links rausgesucht.
Zu äh Leuterungen unter anderem der Landes äh ein einer Landesärztekammer, ich weiß nicht, äh welches Land, äh ob sich das auf das ganze sächsische Landesärztekammer, Entschuldigung.
Einer coronaschutzimpfung kann grober Behandlungsfehler sein
Also ähm habe ich auch noch ein paar äh Videos und Twitters reads, also Ärzte, die von Impfungen abraten, die haben also das Problem, dass sie bei bei Schäden,
durch Erkrankung, ja, also wenn man sich dann äh mit Covid erkrankt,
dann gibt's halt Anspruch auf äh Schmerzensgeld beziehungsweise ähm ja ist es sowohl strafrechtlich als auch zivilrechtlich relevant, also auch für Dienstausfall und solche Sachen können hier äh,
ne und ähm dann hat sich wohl die
Corona-Impfverordnung jetzt am 16.12. dahingehend äh geändert. Da gibt's so ein neues Wording
wo äh der Satz im Rahmen Arzneimittelrechtlicher Zulassung gestrichen wurde, was wohl so viel sagt, dass Ärzte, die jetzt off Label Impfungen machen ähm das dann wahrscheinlich trotzdem abrechnen können, also was auch sozusagen solche,
Maßnahmen ein bisschen mehr mit äh reinnimmt und äh manche Ärzte vielleicht dazu,
raten kann, hier noch flexibler zu impfen.
Ja und off Label Impfung würde jetzt was heißen, einen einen grundsätzlich zugelassenen Impfstoff zu nehmen, aber nicht,
sagen, der in Deutschland jetzt für den Zweck äh was weiß ich, Kinder mit moderner zu impfen zum Beispiel. Wäre, glaube ich, eine offenen Off-Label.
Da
Ja, sage ich mal jetzt lieber nix zu, bin ich mir jetzt gerade nicht so ganz sicher. Das war halt jetzt definitiv bei der Kinderimpfung von fünf bis elf ein Thema und gilt natürlich im Prinzip jetzt ähm er flennt das auch nicht mehr so ein großes Thema.
Äh jetzt wo die Kinder im Großstart, ne.
Nee, aber ich wollte jetzt nur ein Beispiel bringen sozusagen, was man sich jetzt um so eine äh um Unter-Off-Label vorstellen kann. Ich habe auch nur gesehen, dass da auch unter Experten,
die Meinung jetzt noch nicht ganz eindeutig war, was das jetzt eigentlich bedeutet.
So so also ob ob das jetzt zum Beispiel auch umfasst äh äh dass äh ja jetzt ein deutscher Arzt irgendwie Sinovacs äh oder oder äh was auch immer irgendwie einen Chinesischen oder einen kubanischen
Impfstoff hier verimpft oder einen russischen.
Oder U5 okay ähm gut dann sollte man vielleicht mal kurz.
Schauen, was jetzt an Maßnahmen besprochen wurde, denn das jetzt grade ganz frisch, als wir die Sendung aufnehmen Montagabend, zwanzigster zwölfter.
Es wird also es war ja gerade schwer in der Debatte, dass wir jetzt sozusagen über Weihnachten keinen Lockdown bekommen werden. Ähm zumindest keinen der sogenannten wird und ähm jetzt sieht's aber ganz danach aus, dass,
dem 28.12., also wenn der Weihnachtsspaß vorbei ist, dann schon wieder,
heftigere Maßnahmen greifen, Clubs und Discos werden zumachen und äh private Treffen nur noch bis zehn Personen, egal ob Indoor oder Outdoor. Das bedeutet dann auch wiederum keinen,
Zuschauer bei Sportveranstaltungen, also wieder leere Fußballstadion, Geisterspiele et cetera für einen noch nicht näher klaren,
Zeitraum. Das ist natürlich dann, das haben wir jetzt hier auch schon angesprochen, so der Zeitpunkt, wo man davon ausgehen kann, dass Ommikon dann richtig wüten möchte und tja, da haben wir ihn dann also den,
Lockdown.
Sie nennen es Neujahrsruhe.
Okay.
Bund und Länder planen Neujahrsruhe für alle, so äh lautet die Schlagzeile. Nach Weihnachten soll es Kontaktbeschränkungen auch für Geimpfte geben.
Das ist so der das, was die Presse der zentral reininterpretiert ähm.
Also nochmal Klopapier kaufen und äh nein, bitte nicht. Kauft so normal wie immer. Dann funktioniert das nämlich auch.
Clubs und Diskotheken werden geschlossen und Tanzveranstaltungen verboten. Dagegen klagen natürlich jetzt einige
äh Gastronomen und Hoteliers auch, weil natürlich durchaus so zu so Silvesterfeier im Hotel ist halt glaube ich auch so ein Ding, habe ich zwar noch nie gemacht.
Ja, ist es. Oh ja, das ist ein richtiges Ding. Weil.
Ich kann das auch persönlich nicht nachvollziehen, aber typischerweise, wenn du so über Weihnachten irgendwas buchst
dann ist so bis zum 3.12. der eine äh Tarif und dann ab dem 30sten über Silvester gehen die Preise total durch die Decke.
Viele Leute sind dann einfach an so einem Tag im Hotel und wollen da irgendwie Sektchen machen et cetera und natürlich äh fette Partys feiern.
Mit anderen reinfeiern einfach, kann ich kann ich durchaus.
Der kann ja auch total nachvollziehen, aber ist natürlich auch total nachvollziehbar, warum genau das jetzt ein Problem ist.
Absolut.
So insofern also macht es jetzt epidemiologisch äh macht es glaube ich Sinn. Ich meine, das das Problem ist natürlich.
Dass die Inzidenzen überhaupt halt viel zu hoch äh sind äh im Moment und äh das ist das das eigentliche Problem, was wir was wir im Moment haben. Wobei ja der wie gesagt.
Zahlen sind grade auf dem Weg nach unten und.
Denke mal, das wird es auch helfen, dass der Abwärtstrend uns noch eine Weile erhalten bleibt hoffentlich. So und äh ja.
Und.
Bin ich ja nicht so optimistisch. Aber das werden wir sehen, aber wenn man jetzt äh sagt, ist ja eh egal, dann dann kann man's natürlich auch gleich äh komplett bleiben lassen, ne.
Nee, aber ich ich sage mal Kontakt Kontakte reduzieren, verlangsamt auch die Omikron.
Variante und je nachdem wie stark du reduzierst, so äh schafft es sogar auch äh die
Omicon Variante äh ja die die Zahlen runterzukriegen sehen wir ja. Ähm,
äh auch in in anderen Ländern jetzt und äh.
Ja, was auf jeden Fall noch bestehen bleibt, sind halt die zusätzlichen Einschränkungen für Ungeimpfte, also die ganze zwei G Zugangsgeschichte, auch wenn das jetzt hier teilweise durch ähm Gerichte auch schon zum Fall gebracht wurde.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen äh wenn überhaupt noch irgendwelche Veranstaltungen sind oder man irgendwo reingehen kann, muss halt viel äh gescannt werden. Das ist natürlich auch für die Ladenbesitzer totale.
Und für die Leute auch ähm klar, keine Frage, inwiefern das jetzt was gebracht hat, ist, glaube ich, vielleicht noch ein bisschen zu früh zu sagen, aber letzten Endes steht natürlich auch diese Maßnahme im Kontext fallender Zahlen, also zumindest.
Das Gegenteil bewirkt und es ist halt jetzt auch so ein Trend, dass einfach Impfpflichten sich überall langsam,
reinschleichen, habe da noch ein Beispiel aus den USA, da ist es wohl so, dass Google mittlerweile alle Angestellten,
aufgefordert hat bis zum 18. Januar 22 geimpft zu sein, das entsprechend zu belegen, sonst werden sie einen Monat zunächst einmal noch bezahlt zurückgestellt und danach.
Sechs Monate unbezahlt und wenn sie dann immer noch nicht geimpft sind, dann werden sie gefeuert. Das ist sozusagen die Ansage, okay, das ist jetzt USA, würde jetzt so in dem Maße in Deutschland wahrscheinlich nicht äh stattfinden. Ich sage auch nicht.
Macht das so, alle müssen das so machen. Ich sage nur, das das ist das, was sich jetzt so langsam auch entwickelt, ne, weil.
Die Unternehmen einerseits so ihre Verantwortung sehen und natürlich auch so ein bisschen Schnauze voll haben von dem ganzen Scheiß.
Also wo ich.
Ich persönlich einen einen Strich ziehen würde äh wären Genesenen Impfungen. Ja
da die also die helfen in der Regel
auch so, also sind sind eigentlich auch zu empfehlen, aber äh und und das ist.
Das habe ich gehört, ist in den USA wohl in diesen vielen Fällen halt nicht so, dass es egal ist, äh so, dass dass die Impfpflicht eben auch für Genesene gilt.
Und äh ja
und da kann man glaube ich durchaus äh die Position vertreten, äh dass äh
das äh nicht nicht sein sollte.
Das Fass nicht sein sollte.
Dass man von Leuten, äh die genesen sind, die also sich vorher schon mal infiziert haben, dass man sozusagen
die mit Impfpflicht belegt
ja, das halte ich für nicht sachgerecht äh nach allem, was wir über Immunität wissen, nach äh sagen nach durchgemachter Krankheit und nach Impfungen.
Na ja gut, aber ich meine, was heißt denn geimpft? Geimpft hieß bis vor Kurzem,
und noch ein zweiter Shot und dann hast du so diesen magischen Impfstatus gehabt. Jetzt ist zunehmende Maße klar, die Impfung ist in der aktuellen Variantensituation kaum noch was wert.
Gegen die jetzt heranrollende Omikon Variante. Das heißt, geimpft im Sinne von.
Wirklich medizinisch vorbereitet für das, was da real gerade draußen passiert. Bist du halt eigentlich erst mit der dritten? Leute, die heute nicht noch nicht mal die erste Impfung haben.
Würden jetzt nach dem aktuellen Regime vier Monate brauchen, um nur haut bis zu diesem Immunitäts äh Zustand zu kommen. Und es ist in gewisser Hinsicht, ich verstehe, geimpft.
Mehr als Teil des Impfprozesses.
Also dass du natürlich dann auch entsprechend nachliefern äh äh muss und dann es nicht einfach ausreicht jetzt hier mal eine Spritze oder zwei bekommen zu haben und dann zu sagen, ich bin noch geimpft. So und das verfällt natürlich, ne?
Der.
Haben jetzt noch kein offizielles Verfallsdatum, aber ich denke mal, es wird nicht lange dauern und äh wir werden so ein Verfallsdatum von sechs Monaten auf der Zweitimpfung haben, wie's ja Israel schon,
seit Monaten macht, ne und ähm sicherlich ist auch absehbar, dass wir noch eine viertimpfung bekommen mit äh Omnikon Booster, ob der dann auch so verpflichtend sein wird, das wird sich dann noch zeigen.
Aber das ist eigentlich so der Prozess, wo ich die Leute drin sein drin sehen möchte und wenn die jetzt genesen sind im Sinne von Erstkontakt war Infektion.
Gut, dann mag das so in etwa die Dimension einer Erstimpfung haben. Man könnte über Zweitimpfungen nachdenken, aber mehr auch nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich habe äh eine äh äh gerade heute ist mir halt eine ganz gute Studie.
Untergekommen so äh aus aus Israel mit,
richtig richtig großen Zahlen äh so, wo sie halt natürliche
Immunität, verglichen haben mit äh irgendwie natürlicher Immunität und äh äh Impfung oder nur Impfung und so und äh die zeigt halt ganz gut, dass
eigentlich äh äh also unterm Strich äh würde ich sagen.
Ist äh natürliche Immunität scheint besser zu sein, äh so als äh jede Kombination von Impfstoffen, einschließlich Booster, ja?
Gegenüber Omicron.
Äh gegenüber nee das war jetzt bisher gegenüber Delta.
So und gegenüber kann man davon ausgehen müsste sie wahrscheinlich auch nochmal ein bisschen besser
helfen wahrscheinlich, weil äh halt du bei der natürlichen
Immunität, also ich will jetzt nicht für natürliche Immunität werben oder so, um das auch nochmal klarzustellen, das ist halt äh wie gesagt nach wie vor ein Risiko, aber wenn man jetzt einmal äh äh schon mal es ist gehabt hat, äh so
ist der Schutz äh besser als,
mit zwei Impfungen definitiv und hält auch länger. Ich meine, Zahlen sind noch so ein bisschen Spoty
so aber ja grundsätzlich ist, wäre es mal aus meiner Sicht sachgerecht äh zu sagen
äh äh Genesene sind halt von allen Impfpflichten
ausgenommen, ja. Das wäre nach der Studie aus Israel äh würde ich sagen, könnte man das vertreten oder verantworten, ja? Oder sind mindestens äh ich sage mal zweimal geimpften gleichgestellt erstmal.
Noch mal den Link bitte rausholen auf diese Studie, weil es widerspricht so ein bisschen meiner bisherigen Wahrnehmung, weil ich hatte ähm eigentlich.
Aus den allerersten Untersuchungen ähm das so verstanden, dass eigentlich die äh MRNA Impfungen da nochmal deutlich mehr Power äh reingeben.
Also die äh die Kombo natürlich aus Vorerkrankung und äh äh Impfung äh so die.
Also Infektion und Impfung meinst du.
Ja genau, also sozusagen Impfung nach Infektion äh sagen
äh ist tatsächlich äh äh so sorgt für die maximale Immunität. Die haben auch die umgekehrte Kombination untersucht, was es mit Leuten, die halt erstgeimpft,
äh wurden und dann äh danach erkranken. Die entwickeln halt äh äh nicht ganz so einen hohen Schutz.
Also es ist äh wie jetzt die äh aber einen höheren Schutz immer noch als jetzt nur vor Erkrankte.
Aber nicht ganz so hoch wie die Kombination äh sagen erst erkrankt und dann geimpft, weil nach Vorerkrankung erzeugt die Impfung nochmal so äh einen richtigen
Boost äh an Antikörpern, also in Vorerkrankten äh äh war, ähm sagen die Zahl der Antikörper nach der
Impfung äh nochmal so so richtig richtig hoch. Also im Schnitt deutlich höher als bei Leuten, äh die jetzt.
Nach zwei äh Impfungen gekriegt haben oder so. Ich ich suche die mal raus.
Okay.
Lass mal weitermachen mit neuen Impfstoffen. Es gibt nämlich jetzt wieder einen neuen. Äh die EMA hat mal wieder einen zugelassen und wir haben das ja hier schon mehrfach angedeutet, dass das
bald kommen wird. Jetzt ist es soweit. Der neue Impfstoff hört auf den schönen Namen Nuva Xo Vide.
Und ist halt der Impfstoff von der Firma Novacs aus den USA.
Ja und die MA hat also jetzt der EU empfohlen, das Ding äh offiziell zuzulassen, was dann eigentlich nur noch so eine Formsache ist.
Und jetzt äh haben wir also den Impfstoff, der eben insofern was Neues ist, als dass es eben kein MRNA-Impfstoff ist und auch kein äh Vektor-Impfstoff, wie wir das eben bisher ausschließlich hatten.
Sondern eben ein sogenannter Protein äh Impfstoff.
Sprich hier wird nicht wie bei den mRNA Impfstoffen die Zelle, die menschliche Zelle per MRNA-Kommando aufgefordert,
so eine Scheinkopie des Bike-Proteins, des Virus zu erzeugen,
dann aus der Zelle heraus transportiert und dort dann vom Immunsystem erkannt wird, sondern hier werden direkt.
Diese Proteine, die eben aussehen, wie das Virus aber eben nicht das richtige Virus sind äh in den Körper,
reingegeben, sodass das Immunsystem denkt, so oh, böser Angreifer, weil kenne ich nicht. Ich lasse mal Immunsystem hochfahren, ohne dass da halt jetzt wirksame Virusbestandteile drin sind.
Das Ganze geht jetzt auch noch mal so in der Debatte drum und hin und her. Wir hatten das ja hier mit dieser äh,
äh Kimmichdebatte um sogenannte Todimpfstoffe und dann wurde da ja quasi immer drauf referenziert, dass sie sich ja hierbei um einen Tod-Impfstoff handelt.
Ähm hatten wir hier auch schon mal diskutiert, dass das ja eigentlich überhaupt gar kein passender Begriff dafür ist.
Verwendet so eigentlich auch keiner, weil der ist jetzt nicht toter als der mRNA Impfstoff,
Ball gleich tot, weil die an sich nicht lebendig sind, ja. Tod-Impfstoff sind Impfstoffe, wo eben eigentlich vollständige Viren genommen werden, die aber deaktiviert werden
und äh es gibt auch solche Impfstoffe, so inaktivierte Impfstoffe außerhalb des europäischen Zulassungsbereichs, allerdings bisher.
Nur das ist sie halt jetzt eigentlich keiner.
Ja? Es ist eben nur so, dass jetzt hier die Zelle nicht beauftragt wird, dieses Protein zu erzeugen, sondern dass eben das Protein vorher quasi gezüchtet, abgefüllt und dann verspritzt wird.
Ja? Wobei man dann auch sagen muss, dass er im Grunde genommen harmloser ist als ein äh Tod-Impfstoff oder ein deaktivierter äh ja,
Impfstoff oder gibt auch abgeschwächte äh wie auch immer.
Virus, meinst du? Der Impfstoff.
Äh ja äh Virus ja äh äh ja die ja ähm so und das Problem,
ist ist halt je mehr ich von dem Virus oder seiner.
Ja RNA in dem Fall äh drin habe äh in in einem Impfstoff ähm.
Umso gefährlicher ist es, dass äh äh ja äh kann es halt passieren, äh dass,
hm die diese äh Viren oder diese abgeschwächten quasi zurückmutieren, passiert zwar selten, aber dann tatsächlich dann äh wieder anfangen sich auszubreiten und das ist bei jetzt äh Novawachs.
Äh bei diesem Impfstoff, bei diesem Protein-Impfstoff kann das natürlich nicht passieren, weil da sind halt einfach nur,
das Bike-Protein und das kann jetzt ja daraus kann kein kein kompletter Virus,
äh entstehen oder oder heraus mutieren oder so. Insofern äh ja eher harmlos und
und äh damit wären dann eigentlich auch äh ich sage mal alle Bedenken jetzt der Impfkritiker, die immer nach einem Tod-Impfstoff verlangt haben, werden jetzt gegenstandslos, weil.
Sie damit sogar noch was besseres haben und bin gespannt.
Noch toter sozusagen.
Noch toter, also noch toter als tot äh sagen. Es ist dann quasi stattdessen nur ein äh ja statt irgendwie den,
die ganze Leiche ist es dann eben nur, weiß ich nicht, nur ein nur ein Arm oder ein Finger, wenn du so willst. Ähm ja.
Und äh die also was ich halt vermute oder oder die andere Sache ist, dass natürlich sowohl du bei diesem Protein-Impfstoffen als auch bei anderen jetzt Todimpfstoffen oder klassischen Impfstoffen halt adjuvantien brauchst.
So und um jetzt auch mal ja und dieser Novawachs äh Impfstoff ist vielleicht interessant und da fürchte ich ja, da werden sich dann
die Leute drauf stoßen. Das sagen, oh ja, aber irgendwie ähm da ist ja dieses neue M
irgendwie äh drin, deswegen habe ich mir das halt auch nochmal ein bisschen genauer angeguckt, also.
Ist ja so, hatten wir schon mal, dass bei klassischen Impfstoffen ähm.
Man oft äh ja sogenannte,
hinzufügt, meistens irgendwelche Aluminiumverbindungen, Aluminiumkristalle äh die.
Dann das Immunsystem anstacheln und,
dafür sorgen, also die halt quasi künstlich nochmal Entzündungen hervorrufen, denn nur so willst und damit,
eben es überhaupt erstmal ermöglichen, vor allem auch ähm Teezellen äh zu zu bilden, weil äh sonst ohne diese Adjevs hin,
ja äh ist die Immunantwort auch nicht nicht ausgeprägt äh genug und ähm und aber deswegen natürlich auch immer in der,
Kritik von von Impfgegnern oh wollen aber lieber dann sagen noch Bio und Adjevanzien äh frei und ähm in dem Fall ja dieses dieses äh,
Matrix M oder im M eins äh habe ich auch gehört ähm ja ist halt,
Solanin äh neponinin basiert ähm.
Und ähm Saponine sind so seifenartige Substanzen, also eigentlich schön heißt äh
Glycoside und das sind Zucker, Alkoholverbindungen wiederum und ähm ja ich
kannte das nur sagen von von Solanien in in Kartoffeln so bei der Frage irgendwie okay muss ich jetzt meine Kartoffeln eigentlich schälen und oder kann ich irgendwie auch eigentlich Pellkartoffeln essen wegen ja also
gerade in der Schale je nach Sorte äh die enthalten halt das Saponit äh äh Solanin
äh und generell benutzen Pflanzen das als Defensivgifte gegen Pilze und Insekten so. Also es ist,
in dem Fall so ein bisschen ja einen einen Giftstoff äh eben, der aber dann das Immunsystem halt anregt und,
Komische bei den ist, ich habe weiß ich noch nie vor 15 Jahren mal mich mich schlau gemacht hatte über Impfstoffe im Zusammenhang mit dem Golfkriegssyndrom. So
war ich so ein bisschen überrascht, dass so ganz klar, wie und wo Adjurvan jetzt wirken, war es damals nicht und es scheint,
bis heute nicht so vollständig aufgeklärt zu sein. Man kennt so fünf, sechs, sieben Mechanismen, äh wo die je nach
dem Ansetzen, aber äh ja, ich meine, man weiß, dass sie funktionieren und man weiß, dass jetzt auch.
Okay sind, aber
es ist halt schon so ein bisschen unklar und komisch fand ich halt auch dann immer, dass die halt als Hilfsstoffe deklariert sind, aber
eigentlich für die Wirkung halt super entscheidend und auch nicht der normalen Definition von Hilfsstoffen äh so normalerweise so Hilfsstoffe kennt man halt, dass in Pillen irgendwelche
oder Konservierungsstoffe oder auch Stoffe, gut die jetzt die Bioverfügbarkeit beeinflussen, wie es so schön heißt, also irgendwie die Aufnahme in den in den Körper so verbessern, aber
passen da irgendwie auch nicht nicht rein und ich fand,
irgendwie immer so ein bisschen befremdlich, dass äh sagen in dieser Branche oder Wissenschaft
da nicht mal vernünftig zwischen Wirk und Hilfsstoffen
äh äh entschieden wird äh ja aber gut, ist wahrscheinlich für die Praxis jetzt nicht nicht wirklich schlimm, aber nur so
so ein äh äh komisches Ding und ja und,
Was ich auch dann interessant fand, äh hier wie hieß der Spinner mit dem eigenen Impfstoff äh äh noch.
Stücke oder so.
Stöcker, genau, Winfried war das, glaube ich, Winfried, ja. Genau. Äh da hatte ich dann auch mal äh äh geguckt,
äh so äh weil der hat ja sein seinen Impfstoffrezept ja auch im Internet äh veröffentlicht und der hatte auch einen aggurt äh mit
äh drin in in seinem Impfstoff im Übrigen. Also,
Also jetzt wenn wenn Signal an äh jetzt Impfskeptiker oder so äh ja dieses Ativants ähm ja,
äh ist jetzt ja Grund, das hat die grundsätzlichen Probleme von aggressien, aber auf der anderen Seite ähm ja ohne ohne wird man,
nicht weit kommen, beziehungsweise wenn man wenn man kein Active haben will, dann muss man halt einen Vektor oder einen RNA Impfstoff nehmen.
Ich mache mir nicht so richtig viel Hoffnung, da das irgendwelche Impf-Skeptiker jetzt auf einmal von so einer anderen äh Zusammenmischung von irgendwas überzeugt werden. Das wird sich schon schnell wieder umdrehen.
Weiß ich nicht. Ich bin also ein Teil ich ich denke mal einen einen Teil wird es als sagen wir kommenden Ausweg aus der Bredouille in die sie sich gebracht haben.
Ja okay, gut, sodass man so eine Argumentation machen kann, so jetzt ist ja alles anders, mhm.
Genau, dass sie dann sagen können, ja, nee, ich habe ich war ja vernünftiger Impfskeptiker. Ich habe das,
sag mal äh äh nur wegen wegen RNA gemacht und ja,
Es ist halt Angst, dass dann so eine subjektive Bewertung und äh ja, wenn jemand halt,
solche Risiken anders bewertet. Solange kann man sagen, okay ähm dein dein Risiko, Bewertungssystem ist nicht optimal kalibriert, aber.
Ich bin der Erste, der sagt super, wenn es heißt, äh Nova Vags Impfstoff verfügbar
Run auf Erstimpfung äh und so weiter, ja? Also gerne nehme ich sofort mit, mir wirklich Wurst. Man muss natürlich jetzt auch noch mal gucken, wie gut das Zeug wirkt in den Studien, die sie veröffentlicht haben, hatten sie auch eine neunzig
prozentige,
Wirksamkeit nachgewiesen. Das ist ja auch das, womit Modana und Biontech an Start gegangen sind, an sich erst mal ganz gut. Man muss aber nur sagen.
Aus dieser ganzen Studien im Wesentlichen so zur Alphazeit gelaufen sind. Das heißt, schon mit einer Variante, die zwar immer noch sehr ähnlich dem Wildtyp ist, aber eben jetzt mit Omicon nicht mehr so viel zu tun hat. Das Problem haben.
Alle Impfstoffe und man muss natürlich jetzt erstmal schauen, inwiefern das wirkt, aber es äh wird sicherlich nicht keine Wirkung haben.
Ja. Also meine hm meine Einschätzung äh ist die nach den Zahlen, die ich gesehen habe, dass du mit.
RNA Impfstoffen jetzt mit drei Shots ungefähr ja auf gute mit guten fünfundneunzig Prozent und mehr kalkulieren kannst, ja. Aber fünfundneunzig Prozent äh sei mal bei
MRNA Impfstoffen
ist äh denke ich äh oder nach der nach der Zweitimpfung gegen ja die Variante, also gegen die gleiche Variante.
Also ich sage nur, lasst euch mal damit alle mal impfen so und dann lasst mal euren äh Antikörper-Tita äh messen, so die die Latte liegt bei zwanzig achtzig, ne, dass das mal klar ist.
Also nach den Zahlen, äh die ich kenne, äh würde ich sagen, wie gesagt, 59und Prozent bei mRNA und die 90 Prozent jetzt bei Novax, heißt
effektiv, wenn sich das bewahrheitet, dass das ungefähr nur halb so gut schützt. Ja, weil das eine wäre 95 Prozent wäre Schutzfaktor zwanzig
neunzig Prozent wäre ein Schutzfaktor zehn. So. Das kannst du jetzt nach Variante äh mehr oder aber das ist so, ich würde sagen ungefähr äh Größenordnungsmäßig kann man sagen, dass äh ja die Protein-Impfstoffe,
halb so gut schützen wie die mRNA Impfstoffe. Grob übern Daumen.
Ja gut dann würde ich sagen kommen wir mal wieder zu unserem Teil, haben wir ja letztes Mal schon relativ ausführlich behandelt. Ich bin mir gerade jetzt gar nicht so hundertprozentig sicher, ob wir uns nicht hier noch mal ein bisschen wiederholen werden.
Aber
das jetzt so ein bisschen im Mittelpunkt der ganzen äh Planungs-Impfplanungsdebatte und überhaupt Strategiedebatte äh steht, ist natürlich klar. Es rollt jetzt auf jeden Fall zu und bei den sich immer weiter bestätigenden
extrem hohen Infektionsraten.
Weiß ich ganz genau, was die mir so nativ für eine R0 nahegelegt wird, aber ich glaube, irgendwas so zwischen drei und fünf habe ich ähm gehört.
Auf jeden Fall.
Bei Omicon.
Ja, aber omicron.
Also unklar, aber ich würde äh aber es scheint scheint äh,
gewaltig gigantisch zu sein. Ich habe auch auch schon so was gehört wie irgendwie Faktoren von sieben oder acht, äh die in in den Raum geworfen wurden, aber ja.
Vergleich zu Delta.
Ja, ja. Ja und Delta war ja schon, ich sage mal.
Genau und Delta war auch schon wir kommen auch gleich noch mal auf ein paar äh äh Hinweise, was denn der Grund dafür sein könnte. Wir
letztes Mal schon ähm erwähnt, dass so allererste Analysen auch gezeigt haben, okay, da sind jetzt so
drin, die man auch bei anderen coronaviren gesehen hat, also die so die klassischen Erkältungen äh haben, von dem wir ja auch wissen, dass sie extrem ansteckend sind.
Ähm,
Erstmal die Verbreitung. Also wir haben's ja schon erwähnt, so in UK und Dänemark, da ist relativ klar, da ist schon relativ viel. Ähm Spanien geht's wohl auch langsam los.
Ist jetzt alles andere als eine übersichtliche Situation, weil's natürlich dann auch sehr davon abhängig, wie gut diese Länder sequenzieren. Wir wissen ja, dass zum Beispiel, dass Deutschland da jetzt nicht unbedingt grade
Weltmarktführer ist in diesem Bereich, um es mal
zurückhaltend zu formulieren. So oder so, egal, was wir da an den Grenzen schließen oder irgendwie noch für Tests einführen an Flughäfen, äh das wird sich in Europa, die Erfahrung haben wir dann auch schon ein paar Mal gemacht,
nicht nennenswert im Griff ähm bringen lassen, deswegen äh werden wir es einfach überall sehen und das werden wir halt auch innerhalb der nächsten Wochen sehen.
Ähm in UK sind wir jetzt glaube ich so bei mindestens 7ein Prozent.
Noch gibt es in ähm in England, wo es also vor allem derzeit in London wütet noch keine Verdrängung von Delta. Das ist ja auch so eine Frage, die noch so im Raum steht.
Quasi eher ein komplett neues Virus.
Was nochmal koexistiert? Oder ist es eben tatsächlich eine Variante, die dann eben Delta die Luft zum Atmen nimmt?
Wenn dem so ist, wir sehen das in Südafrika, da ist Delta jetzt quasi weg, weil es einfach keine Chance hat, sich gegen,
Ommikorn zu behaupten in London ist das jetzt zumindest Stand 15. Dezember, also Zahlen von vor einer Woche noch nicht so. Aber.
Ich wäre jetzt nicht so überrascht, wenn wir das dann auch bald sehen würden, dass dass Delta verschwindet, aber das ist halt noch nicht klar.
Ähm in UK hat äh ohmy Coin derzeit so eine Verdoppelungszeit von zweieinhalb Tagen,
Ne, das heißt, jede bestehende Infektion verdoppelt sich doppelt so viele Leute, infizieren sich nach zweieinhalb Tagen.
Das ist einfach viel, viel, viel mehr, als wir vorher gesehen haben. Also ich glaube, wir hatten so am Anfang der Pandemie, sind wir so von zehn bis 14 Tagen ausgegangen, glaube ich, ne, bis wir so Verdoppelungszahlen gesehen haben, wenn's so richtig schlimm lief.
Ja und achtfach ansteckender als Date haben wir ja schon gesagt, so dass es so die Größenordnung, in der wir äh hier arbeiten können. Du hast ja die deutschen Zahlen vorhin auch schon mal genannt, ne, also auch da sind ja relativ starke Steigerungsraten zu sehen.
Ja, das vielleicht mal so zur Verbreitung. Jetzt ist eben die Frage, wat.
Ist denn nun, ne und vor allem diese ganze Debatte um die sogenannte milde dieses äh äh Virus, ein schwieriges Wort, weil es jetzt schon so ein bisschen.
Bisschen so in die falsche Debatte rangekommen sind, ne? Weil wenn man sie jetzt von medizinisch, von Miles Simpums redet, so, das ist das eine. Das das ist irgendwie so eine.
Kategorie, mit der dann Mediziner arbeiten können. Aber schnell war das ja dann eben auch so in den Medien mit
Ja, neue Variante, aber total mild, ne und mild klingt dann irgendwie wirklich wie so ein Schaumbad, was man sich dann so nach einem stressigen Tag einlässt, wo man dann erstmal eine halbe Stunde sich bei 40 Grad äh reintunkt.
Das ist natürlich jetzt nicht gemeint. Da ist halt nach wie vor Krankheit dran und je nachdem, auf welche Person
dieses Virus trifft, kann's halt dann eben auch immer noch tödlich laufen. Also so richtig ähm mild im Sinne von wie so ein Cremebad ist es jetzt nicht.
Die Frage ist halt nur, was macht's mit den Leuten wirklich? Wie viele Leute macht es krank und wie schnell macht es vor allem, wie viele Leute wie krank und das ist ja,
generell jetzt der Grund, warum eigentlich alle so beunruhigt sind,
gar nicht mal wegen der Krankheit, sondern weil es sich einfach schneller verbreitet und sich so gut verbreitet.
Dass eben selbst wenn die Leute nicht sehr krank werden, sie aber doch zumindest eben über so Mechanismen wie Quarantäne
einfach auch rausgenommen werden und wenn jetzt hier irgendwie die Feuerwehr, die Polizei äh das Wasserwerk und das Werk irgendwie innerhalb von zwei Wochen keine Mitarbeiter mehr hat, die irgendwo auftauchen können, so dann ähm können's halt auch schnell
schwierig werden. Ähnliches gilt natürlich auch für äh Schulen und andere wichtige Infrastrukturen, you name it. Die.
Ärzte sind aber trotzdem natürlich drauf und dran, also was heißt die Ärzte, die die die medizinischen Forscher, Virologen et cetera sind natürlich drauf und dran sich Omicoren anzuschauen.
Und äh beziehe mich jetzt hier auf einen.
Video von dem letzten Mal schon erwähnten John Cample, der da ja ganz umtriebig ist und sich äh Studien anschaut und der hat ähm.
Zwei Untersuchungen zitiert die ganz interessant sind. Also zunächst einmal vielleicht noch der Hinweis, weil er das auch sagt in London ist es ähnlich wie in Südafrika auch so, dass.
Zwar jetzt sehr viele Leute in den Krankenhäusern sind bei den Corona festgestellt wird.
Aber das wohl nur bei der Hälfte der Leute, die dort im Krankenhaus aufschlagen, dass auch der Grund ist, warum sie da hingegangen sind.
Immer jetzt die anderen Gründe sind, Leute, werden halt auch aus anderen Gründen äh krank oder brechen sich in beiden et cetera. Die schlagen auf jeden Fall im Krankenhaus auf. Im Krankenhaus wird natürlich jeder PCR getestet.
Und dementsprechend wissen sie dann eben, wer hier corona infiziert ist, aber die Leute kommen nicht zwangsläufig alle wegen Corona-Symptomen und Omicon scheint eben jetzt hier zumindest das Bild dahingehend zu verändern, dass eben,
Na ja, es eben zwar bei vielen Leuten festgestellt wird, aber dass es eben nicht so der eigentliche Grund ist, warum sie da sind. Das ist schon mal ganz gut.
Und es gibt jetzt eine erste Untersuchung von Wissenschaftlern an der Hongkong University. Die haben eine sogenannte Ex-Vivo-Untersuchung gemacht, also quasi,
bei Operationen entnommenes Lungengewebe.
Quasi aus dem Körper herausgebracht und dann eben dort mit Omnikorn und Delta infiziert und dann geguckt, was da äh passiert. Das ist noch ein bisschen anders als diese reinen Petrischalen-Laborversuche.
Sich eben hier um wirkliches, richtiges, menschliches Gewebe handelt, aber man das eben nicht im Menschen macht, sondern eben im Labor. Das ist wohl nicht so einfach und in äh,
eine Hongkong University sind, die da wohl ganz weit vorne bei dieser ganzen Technik. Und bei denen ist äh dann aufgefallen, dass der Virus.
Sich ähm.
Vor allem sehr viel schneller in den Zellen der Bronchien. Das sind quasi so die Zugangsröhren zur Lunge.
Verbreitet aber langsamer in der Lunge. Während wir bisher bis delta beim Wildtyp und so weiter genau dieses Problem haben,
dass ähm das Coronavirus sich in der Lunge ganz wohl gefühlt hat, dort viel verbreitet hat,
Das hat natürlich vor allem diese großen Schäden mit schwieriger Atmung et cetera, verklebter Lunge, Langzeitschäden hervorgerufen. Jetzt sieht's so aus, als ob so die Tendenz hat,
schon früher sich quasi festzubeißen, macht dann immer noch Probleme, klar, ne, so wie quasi so wie eine Bronchitis.
Genauso wie eine bronchiert ist, aber es greift eben äh die Bronchien.
Verbreitet sich dort 70mal schneller als Delta und deutlich langsamer, ohne dass ich eine Zahl nehmen kann in der Lunge.
Und ähm das ist insofern ganz interessant, weil das eben konsistent ist mit den Beobachtungen, die derzeit über omikron gemacht werden, nämlich,
Erstmal diese extrem schnelle Ausbreitung.
Das würde das natürlich erklären, weil wenn sich das Virus sozusagen schon in den Bronchien äh verfängt, dort 70 Mal so schnell verbreiten kann.
Ist das natürlich auch der ideale Ort, um auch schnell wieder ausgeatmet zu werden.
Und es könnte eben insgesamt darauf hinweisen, dass das eben für diese.
In Anführungsstrichen milden Verläufe sorgt, also dass quasi im Mittel äh die,
die Krankheit nicht so gefährlich ist. Sie kann im Einzelnen halt immer noch jemanden hart treffen und Leute werden auch davon sterben.
Nur in der Summe ähm läuft es eben anders ab bis hin zu eben solchen Situationen, dass viele Leute gar nicht merken, dass sie das haben und erst wenn sie im Krankenhaus wegen irgendwas auftauchen, dann ist das so.
Auch noch einen indischen Bericht, der auch verlinkt ist, der.
Sich nochmal speziell diese Lungensituation äh anschaut und da bin ich auch schon jetzt äh äh weit über die Grenzen meines medizinischen,
Verständnisses hinaus. Da äh wird irgendwie eine äh geringere Anzahl von sogenannter Fusion ähm.
Beobachtet und das soll halt irgendwie auch ein Grund dafür, dass irgendwie da weniger Ärger in der Lunge macht. Ja.
Ja
So ein bisschen das, was ich da gerade abzeichnet.
All dem Ganzen schwebt natürlich jetzt diese ganze Debatte mit okay, soll äh ist das jetzt so gut, dass man sich so was überhaupt so anschaut und diese Debatte über äh sogenannte milde,
Auswirkungen überhaupt führt, weil wir müssen ja jetzt alle irgendwie uns bedroht fühlen, weil wir brauchen jetzt einfach mal,
Wir müssen auch den Worst Case berücksichtigen und der Worst Case ist natürlich es ist immer noch gefährlich genug, insbesondere für uns und viele Dinge sprechen dafür, dass es sinnvoll ist diese Wachsamkeit auch.
Äh hochentwickelt stehen zu lassen. Ne, da gibt's diese generelle Sache mit,
hohe Infektionsrate bedeutet, sehr viele Leute werden krank und selbst wenn der Anteil der Leute, der krank äh wird, geringer ist, steigt die Zahl, die behandelt werden muss, dass,
sorgt dann für weiteren Druck in den Krankenhäusern und eben,
eben auch Ausfälle in kritischer Infrastruktur. Das ist ein generelles Problem und erst wenn man das ausschließen kann, glaube ich, kann man da seine äh seine seinen Schutzwall wieder runterdrehen.
Und.
Das wird eine Sache noch und das wird natürlich auch dargelegt, weil wir natürlich wir derzeit Vergleiche ziehen im Wesentlichen mit Südafrika und man kann's nicht oft genug betonen, Südafrika,
ist mehrfach durchseucht worden mit mehreren Varianten, hat eine viel jüngere Bevölkerung und von daher,
ganz andere Voraussetzungen als wir.
Wahrscheinlich halb so alt im Schnitt. Also ich weiß es jetzt nicht für Südafrika, aber.
Zehn Jahre weniger im Schnitt, glaube ich.
Afrika generell hat glaube ich neunzehn Komma sieben Jahre und bei uns sind 7undvierzig, ja also.
Die Asylanlage ist höher. Ähm ich glaube, es war 30 oder sowas.
Aber trotzdem, ja, äh ist dürfte das äh schon mal äh irgendwie allein Faktor ziehen bis hundert äh
machen. Also eher Faktor. Äh irgendwas um Faktor zehn, weniger Tote wären zu erwarten. Äh so im im Schnitt. Aber ähm ja.
Ähm und die andere Sache ist zumindest, dass die Daten sind immer noch nicht aus meiner Sicht noch nicht so so richtig
klar äh und ähm so was jetzt so hospitalisierungsraten tatsächlich angeht, wenn du äh erstmal angesteckt bist, also die ersten Zahlen aus Dänemark, die sind aber jetzt schon eine Woche alt
waren ja äh schon noch völlig ja vergleichbar, also irgendwie null Komma sieben äh äh Prozent,
bei ähm jetzt den anderen Varianten und 0,8 Prozent bei um. Also im Grunde genommen ja im Rahmen der
Genauigkeit praktisch genau dasselbe jetzt, weil was die Hospitalisierungsrate angeht. Nur hast du dann natürlich jetzt die vorhin genannten Verzerrungen dann mit den
den Tests, dass halt jetzt.
Gerade wenn du auch hohe Inzidenzen hast, dann hast du natürlich auch viele Leute, die ohne Symptome aber mit Infektion dann auch ins Krankenhaus kommen so und ähm,
Ja also äh so oder so selbst wie gesagt also so harmlos äh kann's gar nicht äh sein, wie wir bräuchten äh bei der äh,
Infektiosität gerade und ähm wie gesagt, meine These ist auch nach wie vor, wenn das auf Ungeimpfte trifft, die Variante dann äh ja, ist da eher weniger mit mit.
Mit harmlos so, weil äh das würde auch zu dem Modell passen, dass du mir gesagt hast, okay, das mag dann, ich sage mal eher
jetzt äh vielleicht oben äh in den in den Atemwegen äh sich stärker vermehren, aber äh wenn es dann trotzdem schafft
wenn das Immunsystem einfach zu lange braucht, so, dann landet es natürlich irgendwann auch unten in der Lunge, also nur weil es sich oben schneller vermehrt, äh heißt es nicht, dass es sich unten in der Lunge dann gar nicht mehr vermehrt, ja.
Also insofern würde wäre das auch auch plausibel, dass die Leute, die geimpft sind, dann äh einfach deren Immunsystem dann genug Zeit hat
zu reagieren bevor sich das dann in der Lunge ausbreitet aber bei.
Ungeimpften äh dass die halt genauso ja eventuell in diesen Immunschock äh dann mal reingehen, wie äh wir das halt.
Gesehen haben bei den anderen Varianten und wüsste ich jetzt nicht warum das jetzt nicht passieren sollte. Ähm,
Also ja ich denke.
Bald wissen. Das ist das das ist das einzig Gute daran.
Ja und und auch wenn wir mal der der Schutz vor Ausbreitung äh durch durch Impfung bei Omikron äh,
nicht groß ist, vielleicht Faktor zwei oder vielleicht drei, wenn du geboostert äh äh bist äh so,
ist es halt aber trotzdem so der Gesamtschutz äh äh glaube ich äh ja.
Also Faktor drei sollte man auch auf jeden Fall mitnehmen, würde ich sagen.
Auf jeden Fall. Ja. So viel zu Omnikorn. Ähm dann gibt's nochmal so.
Trickle trickle kleine Informationen noch nicht so das richtige große Data
Release zu Parkslow wird man letztes Mal glaube ich schon erwähnt, ich hoffe ich hatte das nicht genau so schon mal berichtet
aber scheint weiterhin gut zu wirken. Ende Dezember, also jetzt bald sollen dann die vollständigen Daten releast werden.
Aber sieht halt so aus, als ob das wirklich ein Medikament ist, was nochmal zu 89Prozent gegen Tod bei äh sehr,
stark gefährdeten Patienten
wirken kann, wenn's denn rechtzeitig gegeben wird. Das ist, wie gesagt, so einem mehrtägige Tablettenprozedur, also man muss so fünf Tage oder so, glaube ich, dreimal am Tag
irgendwie zwei Tabletten nehmen oder irgendwo aus einer Größenordnung. Ja genau und ähm erste Laptests sagen, dass es wohl auch.
Bei Patienten hilft, die mit Omnikorn infiziert sind.
Da das eben wohl auch generell sehr unabhängig ist von diesen Spike-Mutationen,
Bei den ganzen Antikörper äh Impfstoffgeschichte wird dieses Bike-Protein eine große Rolle.
Der Level, auf dem dieses Medikament allerdings angreift, in dem es da halt irgendwie auf diese Enzymatik äh Einfluss nimmt und das Virus an der Replikation.
Hindert, dass es ein ganz anderer Mechanismus und von daher ist es irgendwie äh relativ egal. Also da sind sich dann Omicon und die anderen immer noch ähnlich genug, dass das äh Medikament, was.
Ausrichten kann,
Gespannt, wann die Daten kommen, wie die dann bewertet werden, wie lange das dauert, bis es in Europa zugelassen ist, wenn sich das alles so als war, entpuppt, was bisher in Pressemitteilungen und sonstigen Interviews gesagt wird. Ja und dann,
wäre das natürlich wirklich ein Brüller, weil.
All die Leute, die hier zu ungeimpft sind, ne und die dann doch einfach in diese Situation geraten und dann wird's irgendwie schwierig,
könnten natürlich mit so einem Medikament dann wirklich auf den letzten Metern vielleicht noch gerettet äh werden und dann eben auch den Stress von den,
äh von den ganzen Krankenhäusern nehmen. Das wäre so ein bisschen meine Hoffnung.
Dass wir gut, wobei es natürlich dann auch in dem Moment, wo's dann wahrscheinlich weite Verbreitung findet, wir dann, wer weiß, wahrscheinlich auch,
Resistenzen vielleicht sehen werden, wobei gut äh wenn's dann nur bei Infizierten gegeben wird. Äh ja.
Ja, kann ich mir jetzt nicht so vorstellen, dass das so ein großer äh Wirkung haben dürfte. Weiß man nicht, aber das ähm.
Nicht vorstellen, weil es ja nichts weil mit der Verbreitung des Virus zu tun hat. Da kann das Virus ja so gar nicht drauf reagieren.
So als wir hier mal angefangen haben mit dem ganzen Corona-Wiglikram, da war einer der Anlässe warum wir so viel Mitteilungsbedarf hatten, dann auch irgendwann diese digitale Seite.
Und.
Man muss das wahrscheinlich auch irgendwann noch mal komplett aufblättern, aber diese Corona-Warn-App, die gibt's ja erstens immer noch und ist in letzter Zeit auch wieder ein bisschen populärer geworden.
Ich hatte jetzt auch schon mehrfach Warnung ähm und von vielen Leuten.
Auch sozusagen berichtet bekommen, dass sie Warnungen hatten.
Und das zeigt, dass das Ding deutlich verbreiteter ist und mehr benutzt wird.
Ohne dass ich das jetzt konkret benennen kann, dieser ganze Luca-App Wahnsinn scheint ja jetzt auch langsam dem Ende äh entgegen zu gehen
und vor allem, was ich besonders gut finde, ist, dass diese App sich einen zunehmenden Maße eigentlich zu dem entwickelt hat, was eigentlich sein sollte, nämlich ein Hilf,
Reiches Tool bei der,
Bearbeitung dieser ganzen Pandemie und damit meine ich jetzt nicht nur Impfzertifikate zeigen, das ist natürlich ein Feature, was ganz wichtig ist, aber einfach in dem Moment, wo das Ding informiert, wo das Ding Inzidenzen anzeigt, wo einfach,
Sinnvolle Informationen bekommen, was soll ich jetzt tun, wenn das und das passiert.
Das ist in den zunehmenden Maßen in den letzten Wochen und Monaten äh von Release zu Release dort eingebaut worden und das finde ich gut. Also einfach mal so ein Tool zu haben, so äh ein kleines digitales
Klappmesser, was äh alle möglichen Werkzeuge im Angebot hat. Das macht Sinn und vor allem macht es eben Sinn, auch so einen One-Stop-Shop zu haben, dass man einfach sagt, okay Coronapandemie,
Passt zusammen,
Ich brauche nicht irgendwie dreißig Apps, um irgendwelche Aspekte zu machen. Der eine hat das, der eine hat das. Sondern dadurch, dass sich das alles dort konzentriert, macht's natürlich auch die App dann
hilfreicher insbesondere, weil sie eben immer noch diese Abstandswahn-Geschichte macht und sie einem selbst wenn man jetzt diese Warnung nicht unmittelbar,
ernst nimmt und Anlass hat äh jetzt zu glauben, dass man infiziert ist und PCR-Test macht,
Auf jeden Fall tragen diese Warnungen dazu bei, einem so ein Gefühl für die Infektionsmenge, die so unterwegs ist und die Bedrohungslage um einen herum zu geben,
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein wichtiger Punkt und wie schon vor einem Jahr gesagt, dass es auch so etwas wovon ich eigentlich noch mehr sehen würde, aber,
Egal, so ist es nun mal. Warum bringe ich das jetzt noch mal auf, ähm weil da wirklich sehr viel passiert und mittlerweile ähm gehen sie auch diese Problematik an, dass dieses ganze.
Impfzertifikat zeigen ähm auch so ein so ein so ein so ein oft benötigter Prozess ist, ne. Ich bin jetzt äh ja auch mal,
Urlaub gewesen, habe ich ja erzählt so und überall egal Spanien oder Israel muss halt irgendwie dein dein Ding hochladen und dann konntest du am Anfang davon noch nicht mal irgendwie.
Kopie machen. Du hattest es zwar auch in der App, aber wie wolltest du es dann hochladen und ne, gab keine Schermenüs und keine Ahnung, dann solltest du irgendwelche Screenshots machen, also es war alles total schwierig.
Jetzt gibt's in der neuesten Version tatsächlich so eine Implementierung eines
validierungsworkflows, das heißt, es wird jetzt darauf hinauslaufen, dass bestimmte Anbieter.
Unter anderem die Telekom, ein Service anbieten, ja, also quasi so ein ich überprüfe dein Zertifikat, ob es stimmt, ob es gültig ist.
Also das, was man auch in dieser Koffpass-Check-App äh drin hat und teile das Ergebnis, nicht aber das Zertifikat einer interessierten dritten Stelle mit verbindlich. Sprich,
Beispiel Flugreise, Einreise in ein anderes Land.
Meine Fluggesellschaft erwartet von mir, dass ich meine Impfung nachweise.
Vollkommen normaler Vorgang mittlerweile. So will man natürlich so einfach machen wie möglich. Das könnte also künftig so laufen, dass die Webseite einem dann einen QR-Code präsentiert, also nicht ich der Webseite, sondern die,
Webseite mir, indem im Wesentlichen codiert ist hallo.
Ich möchte gerne folgenden Impfstatus von dir abfragen und dann ist halt die Frage, was da genau drin grundiert werden kann, weiß ich nicht ganz genau, so dritte Impfung, Abstand.
Anforderungen, Name, Geburtsdatum, ne, von den Buchungsdaten von meinem Ticket und ähm das kenne ich dann mit der Corona-Warn-App diesen QR-Code, der quasi nur die Anforderung ist,
In diesem QR-Code steht drin, über welchen dritten Dienst hier die Überprüfung vorgenommen werden soll. Da könnt ihr da also drin stehen, so ja hier, Telekom macht voll geil äh QR-Code, die können voll geil QR-Code äh scannen.
Gelernt und dann überträgt die Corona-Warn-App an diesen Dienst das Zertifikat.
Guckt sich das an und sagt, okay, alles klar, passt schon. Und das Ergebnis dieser Überprüfung, das wird dann wiederum der Fluggesellschaft mitgeteilt, die dann nicht eine vollständige Kopie meines Zertifikats erhält, sondern eben nur die Information, ja, okay, hier.
Was du wissen wolltest, das kann ich dir bestätigen.
Ne und dieser Validierungsdienst soll natürlich auch nicht das Zertifikat speichern oder darf das nicht tun so, aber dadurch reduziert man eben die Zahl der Stellen, wo überhaupt Kopien,
Auch nur temporärer Art äh auftauchen von diesen Zertifikaten. Macht eigentlich äh total Sinn.
Würde ich würde ich auch sagen, also zumindest auch in der in der Praxis kann sowas dann,
durchaus, ja, Daten, die Wahrscheinlichkeit von Datenlegs reduzieren, äh sage ich mal, wenn die Überprüfung wirklich so stattfindet, dass halt ja,
da nichts gespeichert wird und stattdessen halt nur ein neues Zertifikat ausgestellt wird, was äh sage ich Ihre Quittung für meine Quittung äh.
Genau.
Und ja insofern denke ich ja ist jetzt ist jetzt nicht verkehrt.
Auf der anderen Seite so denke ich mir ist natürlich grundsätzlich so die Verbreitung von Systemen, die irgendwie deine Bewegungsfreiheit einschränken aufgrund irgendwelcher
Äh ja QR-Codes ähm so das kann ich jetzt grundsätzlich, ich sage mal, nicht gutheißen, aber äh ja
Ähm im Moment wahrscheinlich auch nicht wirklich zu vermeiden das Ganze.
Nee, nicht zu vermeiden und ist ja jetzt auch nichts Neues, ne? Also ich meine, äh Gelbfieberimpfung musstest du schon immer nachweisen, wenn du irgendwie eine entsprechende äh Betroffene Gebiete fährst, so bloß bis
bisher ist halt diesen gelben Lappen da gezeigt und du willst halt so was jetzt in so einem Online-Prozess auch mal durchführen können.
Aber es ist dann schon ein Unterschied,
du das dann äh sagen äh bei Zutritt zu jedem Büro, zu jeder Fabrikhalle, in jedem Flugzeug, in jeder Straßenbahn, jedem Hotel oder in jedem Restaurant und bei jedem Event.
Vorzeigen musst, wie halt äh T-Systems wirbt dafür, ja? Das also.
Wie gesagt, ja, also ich würde sagen, da schlagen halt gerade zwei Herzen in meiner Brust. So auf der einen Seite ähm,
Ist mir jetzt lieber wenn wenn äh schon irgendwie digital dann bisschen vernünftiger äh statt.
Jetzt wie so was wie Luca irgendwie ähm da bin ich bin ich dann äh immer äh eher dafür, also,
ja
Auch CVA, ich habe mich nirgendwo per Lou ich hab's tatsächlich geschafft, ohne Luca durchzukommen und mittlerweile äh kann man sich ja auch mit der CWA fast überall äh einchecken. So, insofern?
Äh
Allein das war jetzt so ein so ein Ding, aber ja trotzdem grundsätzlich ja äh gefällt mir das nicht.
Na ja, ich meine, man muss ja zwei Sachen trennen. Die Anforderung, so etwas zeigen zu müssen, um irgendwo Zugang zu erhalten, ist das eine.
Ja? Das andere, wenn es so lange ist, äh wie schlecht kann es dann sein, dass es ja immer die Frage und wir haben einfach zu viele Beispiele für, wie schlecht kann es sein. Ich sage nur,
Impftermine äh und so weiter. Bei all dem Schmerz, den wir gehabt haben,
ja ich habe noch nie so viel Fortschritt gesehen in so kurzer Zeit. Das hat sich wirklich.
Auch entwickelt auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise, weil einfach diese Notwendigkeit auf einmal da ist und das hat auch was Gutes.
Ja meine Befürchtung äh ist halt nur, dass das sozusagen Hemmschwellen senken könnte, dass dann auch für andere Zwecke einzusetzen, zum Beispiel als jetzt für Pandemiekontrolle.
Oder,
dass man sagt, wir weiten wir wir machen jetzt permanente Pandemiekontrolle so. Äh sagen, wir machen das. Wir führen das Ganze auch in der interpandemischen Phase fort.
Glaube nicht, dass es irgendwo wirklich nennenswerte Begeisterung dafür gibt. Auch in der Politik nicht.
Sind einfach nach wie vor alles nur Notwendigkeiten. Und ich weiß, solche klar könnte das irgendwie irgendjemanden darin äh beglücken, aber ich glaube einfach nicht, dass das gesellschaftlich langfristig gewollt ist. Deswegen wird das dann auch nicht stattfinden. Aber.
Okay, dass man mal über äh sinnvolle Serverstrukturen nach.
Äh ja ja sozusagen dann dein dein Anti-Terror-Zertifikat äh so für weil ja es.
Jetzt äh ich meine, das ist tatsächlich durch, durchaus so ein Traum äh oder so eine Vision von ähm,
ja um um die Abfertigung an Flughäfen zu beschleunigen, indem du dann quasi Passagiere hast
die halt irgendwie sich vorher einer besonderen Prüfung unterzogen haben und besonders vertrauenswürdig äh sind und dann weniger kontrolliert werden müssen. So, also.
Gut, aber das hast du heute auch schon in Form von Personalausweis und elektronisch lesbaren äh Reisepässen und dahinter geschalteten Datenbanken, in denen das dann einfach drinsteht. Also die IDs sind ja da. Da brauchst du jetzt kein zusätzliches Antiterrorzertifikat.
Es geht ja eher um die andere Geschichte sozusagen, um Erleichterungen für äh äh ja also.
Sofern das so halt dein dein Gepäck dann auch nicht.
Egal. Was soll's. Äh das sind jetzt alles nur ja Spekulationen, äh Warnungen, äh einfach mal auf aufzupassen und also es sind Dinge jedenfalls, wo es zumindest gilt, Ausschau nachzuhalten.
Ja, ich bin voll dafür, immer auf alles aufzupassen. Ich bin voll dafür, aber ich habe auch wirklich Schwierigkeiten
in jeder kleinen Verbesserung irgendwie in diesem ganzen Umgang mit der Pandemie, die diese Corona-Warnapp einfach mal darstellt,
Ja, also es ist einfach der Versuch, die Dinge auch besser händeln zu können und dann bauen sie irgendwie wieder ein Feature ein
womit man irgendwas besser handeln kann und dann immer gleich mit dieser Dystopie-Keule zu kommen so
oh aber ich könnte mir, wenn ich mich lang genug bekifft auf mein Sofa legen, 21 Millionen verschiedene äh Szenarien zusammenlegen, wie das vielleicht unter Umständen in einer jetzt nicht so spontan zu formulierenden Art und Weise
ganz was Böses sein kann.
Einfach nicht mit bei diesen ganzen Debatten. Also man kann das natürlich klar besprechen, man kann sich das Protokoll anschauen, kann sagen so hier da dieses und jenes, das muss irgendwie anders gemacht werden, aber dann muss man auch wirklich mal konkret sein und nicht immer in so einem Buschiwaschi-Modus.
Nein bei der CWA sind wir uns da ja völlig völlig einig äh so. Ähm das ist,
Das ist eine äh äh tatsächlich da sind viele pfiffige äh Privatsphäre schonende Lösungen äh drin äh äh.
Würde ich würde ich das mal nennen und ich würde mir wünschen und sagen es es gebe mehr solcher Lösungen auch in anderen Bereichen, wo man sich
ausweisen muss, äh was weiß ich, in Zahlungsverkehr oder bei der Anmeldung im Hotel
oder keine Ahnung bei anderen Dingen, bei
Kauf von irgendwelchen Dingen da. Also da sehe ich, ich sage mal sicherlich auch durchaus positive äh.
Tendenzen oder das sozusagen damit besser, aber nichtsdestotrotz äh entwickle ich mich schon so ein bisschen, aber auch zu einem Digitalisierung.
Äh Skeptiker äh und nein, ich habe ich habe viele Zutrittskontrollsysteme und Lösungen äh so auch immer wieder in meinem Leben.
Gebaut oder gesehen oder integriert oder so, deswegen und auch habe auch im Bereich der Flughafensicherheit ein bisschen äh was gemacht
ist das jetzt nicht das ist jetzt keine
sagen Verschwörungs äh äh Theorie und ich will da jetzt auch keine technikgroße Technik Skepsis erzeugen, sondern nur nur ähm,
dann doch mal meinem meinem leichten, ich sage mal mulmigen,
Bauchgefühl Ausdruck geben, was glaube ich auch andere Leute verspüren äh ja ähm wenn sie halt überall irgendwo was vorzeigen müssen, ja.
So, aber ich gebe dir Recht. Ich ich hoffe, es kommt so, wie du sagst, dass äh tatsächlich äh sagen, dass ein Kind der Notwendigkeit ist und dass das jetzt
äh keinen Gewöhnungseffekt äh äh haben äh wird, äh sondern dann auch wieder verschwindet. Aber,
Ich sehe da eine einen Restrisiko. Nennen wir's nennen wir's Restrisiko.
Meinetwegen. Ja äh überprüfen von Informationen war auch ein Thema in äh Slowenien. Da gab's einen schönen Fall, dass sich jemand 23 Mal hat impfen lassen.
Nicht weil er so geil auf die Impfung war, sondern weil er sich quasi von anderen Leuten, die sich nicht impfen lassen wollten,
hat bezahlen lassen dafür, dass er sich statt ihrer impfen lässt, aber damit ihrer Krankenversicherer aufgelaufen ist, weil halt die Krankenversichertenkarte in Slowenien kein Foto hat.
Er hat sich einfach die Krankenversicherung von irgendjemanden geben lassen. Es gab keine Pflicht, auch noch einen Personalausweis oder was Vergleichbares zu zeigen, sondern nur diese Karte hat ausgereicht.
Also hat er sich irgendwie dreiundzwanzig Mal impfen lassen und dann irgendwie zweiundzwanzig von diesen Impfungen äh weiterverkauft. Quasi weiß ich genau, wie viel Geld da genommen hat, aber das ist,
auch echt hardcore. Das Schöne da dran ist.
Will jetzt noch mal was gegen die Impfstoffe hören, wenn man sich 23 Mal davon impfen lassen kann und man läuft irgendwie immer noch auf diesem Planeten, dann kann das so schlimm nicht gewesen sein.
Ich will jetzt auch nochmal zehn.
Ja
Ja ja ich meine ja im im Long Tale findest du wirklich Leute, die äh ja ich ich meine wie kann man nur auf so eine Idee kommen, ja aber äh,
äh so ähm.
Also in beide Richtungen, ich sage mal, wie kann man auf die Idee kommen, jemanden für sich zur Impfung zu schicken, wie dann immer, ja äh ja okay, kann ich nachvollziehen, ja, aber dann,
Stattdessen irgendwie 23 Mal sich impfen zu lassen irgendwie, das ist schon.
Gut, ich meine, es gibt Leute, die haben Angst. Der äh hat definitiv das Gegenteil, ja? Also der der hat also wirklich mit Abstand keine Angststörung, sondern ist vielleicht schon in einer anderen äh Hinsicht pathologisch.
Überhaupt gar keine Angst entwickelt und überhaupt keine Bedenken. Also sie denkt so sind die denn blöd nur fürs Impfen? Lassen die sich hier.
Geben die dann so viel Geld aus, mir soll's egal sein, gebt her irgendwie kein Problem. Aber wenn einer wirklich ordentlich geschützt ist, also den sollte man auf jeden Fall in eine Studie mit reinnehmen.
Dann äh eine Kleinigkeit. Äh ich verlinke euch einen Artikel auf Spektrum DE. Da sind nämlich mal Antigen-Tests getestet worden.
Und äh ohne das jetzt groß zusammenfassen zu wollen, aber ähm da wird schon mal genauer hingeschaut, weil einfach sehr,
viele Antigen-Tests halt auch nicht unbedingt jetzt so gut sind, ne? Und es gibt ja da verschiedenste
auf die man da äh achten soll, also wie genau wird ein Wert äh erkannt und von anderen unterschieden. Also kann sich ein Antigentest quasi von anderen äh Dingen ablenken lassen und reagiert auf etwas, was gar nicht Corona ist.
Der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite, äh wie viel Viruslast muss er nun wirklich da sein?
Das da drauf äh eingegangen wird. Wir haben das hier vor mehreren Sendungen mal ausführlich äh diskutiert. Ich glaube, das muss irgendwann im Sommer gewesen sein.
Ähm hat's über den Schnelltest losging.
Mit Sensitivität und Spezifizität et cetera auf jeden Fall der Link ist in den Shownotes und dann könnt ihr halt gucken, wie gut die Tests denn äh sind. Ich habe zur
Zufriedenheit festgestellt, dass gleich der erste in dieser Liste, ich weiß aber nicht genau, wonach die sortiert sind hier bei nach Viruslast.
Ähm also bei sehr hoher Viruslast erkennt der
ich habe noch sehr zuverlässig, ähm müsst ihr halt gucken, also,
Ich will da jetzt gar keine Empfehlung geben, weil ich habe mir die Liste jetzt auch nicht komplett auswendig draufgeschaffen.
Ja wir hatten da ja mal einen einen ausgiebigen eine ausgiebige Diskussion äh äh darüber und.
Jetzt gibt's ja ja da offensichtlich mehr Erfahrungen und.
Auch äh von verschiedenen Seiten auch noch gehört, hm Erfahrungen mit Tests zum Beispiel im im Klinik,
Alltag oder äh äh und da gab's halt vor allem Probleme, also die, die auffällig waren, waren halt mit Falsch-Positiven und es gab da dann Leute, die halt.
Mit einer bestimmten Sorte von Test immer positiv getestet wurden, aus welchem Grund auch,
immer so klar wurde das nicht äh und
denen es halt dann dreimal hintereinander sind die halt positiv getestet worden, mussten sich dann selbst isolieren, PCR-Test machen, PCR negativ so. Wenn du und
irgendwann, ja wir können doch jetzt nicht irgendwie jede Woche hier äh durch die dieses Theater veranstalten, dann haben die halt einfach einen anderen Test,
äh genommen und dann äh ging's, dann gab's halt keine positiven mehr so. Ja,
und äh in insofern äh ja scheint sich jetzt auch aus dieser Untersuchung äh zu bestätigen, dass,
die Schnelltests, auch wenn sie sicherlich ja,
was was bringen man sich nicht wirklich drauf verlassen kann auf die meisten Tests. So.
Anguckst bei sozusagen hoher Viruslast so äh ist bei den meisten Tests je nachdem wie ihr,
jeder 2. oder,
jeder dritte äh rutscht halt durch so bei bei manchen Tests sogar irgendwie äh drei von vier oder drei von fünf oder vier von fünf sogar, ja und.
Das ist natürlich ein ziemlich.
Weitmaschiges Netz und selbst die besten Tests äh ich meine immer mit 87 Prozent äh rutscht nur einer von ja.
Sind das äh nicht ganz einer von äh etwas mehr als einer von zehn äh so rutscht halt durch.
Und äh ja also wie du schon sagtest.
Auf jeden Fall mal sinnvoll sich diese äh Liste anzuschauen, denke ich mal.
Mal zu gucken, ob euer Test, den ihr gerade rumliegen habt, vielleicht so äh komplett autoskop ist. Also ist zumindest schon mal überprüft worden. So und das ist ja auch mal was. Weil die Behörden.
Quasi Zulassungskriterien für dieses Test machen ja, die testen nicht alle durch, sondern das ist dann einfach alles so ja ja nee das äh erfüllen wir alle, Stempel drauf, fertig.
Irgendwie eine Nummer und ähm hier wird halt mal so richtig überprüft, wie es denn nun wirklich ist.
Ja, das hatten wir das hatten wir damals in der Sendung,
auch erwähnt äh und kritisiert, so dass die Prozesse, äh sie sehen wohl so aus, dass die Firmen halt,
jemanden beauftragen müssen, der das Ganze prüft und die ganze Prüfung äh läuft auch mit einer Reihe von ja Mustern
äh ab, also sie wird wird nicht jetzt an Patienten getestet oder so, sondern an,
paraten an an äh künstlichen das Ganze äh und auch an einer nicht besonders hohen Zahl und
ja das hat natürlich mit dem Alltag äh nicht unbedingt viel zu tun, so
äh ja, weil.
Nachdem wieder Abstrich genommen wird und äh die Einsatzbedingungen und Temperaturen und was da nicht alles dann noch noch,
kann, das geht alles nicht in die Tests äh mit ein, das wird alles nicht wirklich getestet, sondern die finden unter standardisierten Bedingungen statt.
Und auch noch äh wie gesagt nicht durch offizielle Behörden, sondern durch private Beauftragte, Labors von den Firmen, die diese Tests anbieten und in beiden Schritten äh sagen,
gibt's natürlich Anlass äh zu Verzerrungen, sage ich mal oder Fehlern oder wie auch immer. Ja.
Dann fand ich noch äh schön dieses kleine Detail habe ich aufgeschnappt, das äh Christian Drosten nur noch Interviews macht wenn die nicht hinter einer Paywall verschwinden.
Das ist ähm.
Fand ich ein sehr schönes Detail und sehr angemessen auch weil es ist schon etwas, was mich auch ein bisschen nervt. Ich meine Payboys sind natürlich generell so ein Problem, auch wenn ich verstehe, warum so was gemacht wird.
Des Journalismus et cetera.
Nur in so einer Pandemie ist das irgendwie so ein bisschen so. Hier die wichtigste Information, morgen nicht äh an der Pandemie zu sterben. Klick hier irgendwie doller, dollar, Dollar.
Und äh da äh sieht sich natürlich Drosten sicherlich in großer Gefahr da so ein bisschen der,
ein zum Eintreiber für solche Payball-Systeme äh zu werden. Und finde ich gut, dass er das nicht macht.
Jo
Würdest du auch nicht machen, ne.
Ja.
Na ja, es ist es ist dann halt immer so äh zu sagen, klar, ja Leistungsschutz äh so ich meine
Äh klar ist es natürlich auch eine Leistung äh ein gutes Interview zu führen und dann irgendwie auch äh ja äh,
das zu veröffentlichen und zu transportieren und äh so, aber völlig recht äh so ähm.
Ja ähm das das hat ein Geschmäckle.
Und deswegen kann ich das kann ich das gut nachvollziehen.
Denke, jetzt sind wir am Ende der Sendung angekommen, Pavel für diese Woche, für diesen Monat und für dieses Kalenderjahr.
Oh mein Gott.
Noch nicht unbedingt für diese Welle äh.
Schon wieder ein Jahr rum, ey. Ich weiß noch äh äh ja, wie wir vor einem Jahr so auf äh.
Jahr 2021 geblickt haben und äh überlegt haben, ob das wohl besser oder oder schlimmer wird und ja ich weiß nicht, wie ist denn dein.
Eindruck.
Besser war's schon.
Ja also.
Also das fand ich richtig geil, aber es war besser. Ich meine, er fand im Sommer auf jeden Fall schon mal mehr statt als im Sommer davor. Äh es hat sich ein bisschen nach hinten geschoben. Unnötigerweise, aber ähm ja und das wird auch im nächsten Jahr so sein.
Ja aber gut ja ich meine gut wir hatten natürlich die Impfung äh so aber ich würde sagen mal trotz Impfung äh war's jetzt nicht wirklich toll so.
Ja das stimmt. Also die Hoffnungen, die wir in die Impfung gesetzt haben äh ein bisschen getrogen worden.
Und ähm ja auch die die Reaktionen so, also es ist ein bisschen hier und da ein bisschen mehr Vernunft eingekehrt äh würde ich sagen, aber auch.
Ziemlich viel Irrsinn und dann äh ja.
Also ähm ich persönlich fühle mich schon ganz schön gebeutelt auch noch von von diesem ja, also ich muss sagen, also noch noch so ein Jahr brauche ich eigentlich nicht. Äh.
Wie du es wie du das siehst so, aber.
Rauch, glaube ich, keiner wirklich. Nein, es es ist es ist es ist halt auch,
wie es ist. So und ähm das ist vielleicht meine persönliche Art und Weise mit solchen Tragödien äh umzugehen.
Ich merke immer, ich fühle mich gleich sehr viel besser, wenn ich äh vor allem mich erstmal damit abfinde, dass die Situation jetzt,
genauso ist, wie sie ist, egal wie scheiße sie jetzt äh grade ist. Ist halt so und ähm dann.
Alles, was dann passiert, kann eigentlich nur noch Hoffnung machen und äh hat potenziell zu Verbesserungen. Also man immer nur darüber klagt, wie schlimm irgendwas ist oder wie schlimm irgendwas war, ist ja eigentlich nichts gewonnen.
Man konzentriert sich am besten auf das, was kann ich jetzt irgendwie konkret verbessern, was kann ich selber gestalten oder was kann ich zumindest so aktiv verfolgen, dass ich das Gefühl habe, einem auf äh on top of things. Und das ist ja auch,
einer der Gründe, warum wir diesen Podcast gestartet haben. Einerseits natürlich für.
Eine Öffentlichkeit, so, also die konkret eben diese Mieterebene äh Community, Leute, die sagen, okay, da.
Kommen Dinge raus, die relevant für mich sind. Da mag mir nicht alles passen, aber das das bedient mich, das holt mich ab, das das das
liefert mir Aspekte, Einblicke, Ideen, Inspirationen, was auch immer man sich da einzeln rauszieht, so und äh und wenn sie halt auch nur so ein kleines Coronalagerfeuer ist, der ähm,
Betroffenen, ja, das das ist sicherlich auch ein,
ähm Effekt oder kann ein Effekt sein, dieses Podcast. Das mal so auch, sagen wir mal, in seiner Verzweiflung dann vielleicht nicht alleine ist und.
Andere Sichtweisen hört oder zumindest dann eben Bedenken auch geteilt bekommt. Aber es war dann eben auch sehr wichtig für mich persönlich und ich glaube, das ist bei dir auch ähnlich,
dieses wenn schon Katastrophe dann äh will ich aber auch alle Details mit
kommen so, dann dann möchte ich auch irgendwie das Gefühl haben, da so eine gewisse Verankerung in dem Thema zu haben
um eben nicht auch so schnell weggeschwemmt zu werden, wenn irgendwas passiert. Und ich glaube, vielen Leuten geht es so, dass sie in so einer halbinformiertheit einfach verunsichert sind von all,
den entweder schlecht kommunizierten Fakten auf der einen Seite oder den viel zu gut kommunizierten non.
Und in diesem diesem Wogen von dem ganzen Informations hin und her dann einfach auch schnell verloren sind. Und dann eben schnell auch an diesen Punkt kommen mit,
Ich kann jetzt niemanden mehr trauen. Ich kann niemandem mehr glauben. Ich ich sehe mich nicht in der Lage hier für mich eine eigene feste Meinung zu bilden an mit der ich auch für mich äh
anfangen kann, aus denen ich die richtigen Schlüsse ziehe.
Das war für mich persönlich sehr wichtig, an diesem Punkt zu kommen und deswegen ist äh in gewisser Hinsicht so ein Podcast halt auch immer äh Selbsttherapie.
Ja ja, auf auf jeden Fall einen Bewältigungsmechanismus äh für mich auch. Es hatte aber auch noch mehr Funktionen auch, die,
Twitterei, äh die ich dann äh so auch äh doch doch stark verstärkt habe. Äh also es äh ist auch so ein bisschen so eine Art Pandemie-Tagebuch.
So um auch sagen hinterher vielleicht sehen zu können oder nachvollziehen zu können so okay wie habe ich mich denn da gefühlt und natürlich mir auch bewusst zu werden ähm so,
wie ich den fühle oder oder denke über bestimmte Dinge oder wie ich die einschätze. Ähm.
Aber.
Was definitiv funktioniert hat äh bei mir ist, dass ich jetzt vor dem Virus glaube ich äh,
aber auch nicht zu viel Angst äh habe so, dass ich den eigentlich glaube ich ganz gut einschätzen kann und nicht irgendwie äh das Gefühl habe, in der Lage bin, mich durchaus auch davor zu schützen,
Ähm so aber äh meine ich ich nenn's mal
Angst vor dem Virus ist jetzt dann mehr in einer Angst vor nur sagen
der Reaktion oder Nichtreaktion auf seine Verbreitung gewichen, ja? Oder
äh äh ich weiß nicht, ob ich das Angst nennen will, aber doch ja schon die die Befürchtung, dass halt die
äh Reaktion von Öffentlichkeit und Politik halt jedes Mal doch wieder deutlich suboptimal ausfallen und dass wir eine bessere Politik verfolgen würden, äh dass es wesentlich stressfreier
sein könnte. Aber gut. Auf der anderen,
Seite ist das Gras dann halt eh immer grüner und ähm hm aber.
Ja, nach wie vor, ich ich glaube halt nach wie vor daran, dass eine schnelle und frühe äh Reaktion äh dann,
eine äh späte und dann lang andauernde Reaktion äh äh halt vorzuziehen ist.
Aber,
Auf der anderen Seite ändert sich natürlich der Mix auch durch die Impfungen jetzt und durch individuelle Risikoeinschätzung. Wir wissen jetzt tatsächlich sehr, sehr viel mehr so.
Und es ist die Pandemie ist halt auch sehr, sehr viel komplizierter geworden, weil wir äh so viel mehr wissen und äh ja.
Pandemie ist kein Wunschkonzert, da muss man's nehmen, wie's kommt. Und äh damit klar.
Ja, ja, ich na ja, na ja, na ja, äh aber man kann's immer noch machen wie die Tschechen. Äh so.
Nicht empfohlen, nicht von diesem Podcast empfohlen.
So nicht von diesem Podcast empfohlen, aber das ist halt dann äh ja.
Gut, ich denke jetzt machen wir hier mal einen äh Punkt. Das war's. UKW 8achtzig vom zwanzigsten. Dezember.
21 und ähm ja wünschen euch einen schönen Jahresausklang. Was auch immer ihr noch organisiert bekommt in eurer Runde.
Ja und frohes Fest und guten Rutsch und äh ja, äh gute Immunität.
So weit sind wir schon. Wir würden wünscht den anderen Leuten gute Immunität. Na ja, warum nicht? Äh das war's. Bis bald. Tschüss.
Ja. Ciao.